hey everyone and welcome to this live
machine learning tutorial 2022 by simply
alone
in this session we'll be covering
machine learning in depth starting from
very beginning our experienced
instructors will take you through this
live course
below are the topics that we'll be
covering for this video
so we'll start with basics of machine
learning and then we'll understand
machine learning versus deep learning
versus artificial intelligence
next we're going to look at the
different types of ai and machine
learning followed by
the various applications of machine
learning in different industries
moving ahead
we'll explore the machine learning
algorithms such as clustering logistic
regression linear regression random
forest and naive bayes
you will learn who is a machine learning
engineer about machine learning engineer
salary roles and responsibilities
finally
you will understand about the top
machine learning interview questions
that are frequently asked during the
interviews
so let's begin now
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from their past data
and do what humans can do and much
faster well that's called machine
learning but it's a lot more than just
learning it's also about understanding
and reasoning so today we will learn
about the basics of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity let's just use tempo and
intensity for now so here tempo is on
the x axis ranging from relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging from light to soaring we see
that paul likes the song with fast tempo
and soaring intensity while he dislikes
the song with relaxed tempo and light
intensity so now we know paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a song a has fast
tempo and a soaring intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not correct so paul likes this
song by looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily right let's say now
paul listens to a new song let's label
it as song b so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether ball likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if you draw a circle around the song b
we see that there are four words for
like whereas one would for dislike if we
go for the majority votes we can say
that paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs 4 grams your
model will predict the currency of the
coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of three grams it will be a one rupee
coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight of
the new coin your model will predict the
currency hence supervised learning uses
labeled data to train the model here the
machine knew the features of the object
and also the labels associated with
those features on this note let's move
to unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis by
looking at the data you'll clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored
higher runs and took less wickets while
the other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
a reward based learning or we can say
that it works on the principle of
feedback here let's say you provide the
system with an image of a dog and ask it
to identify it the system identifies it
as a cat so you give a negative feedback
to the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario 1 facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fair of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the surge pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with a goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 00 pm today okay
i'll remind you thanks no problem
comment below some interesting everyday
examples around you where machines are
learning and doing amazing jobs so
that's all for machine learning basics
today from my site keep watching this
space for more interesting videos until
then happy learning simply learn
welcomes you to
machine learning versus deep learning
versus artificial intelligence some of
the most exciting technologies evolving
in today's world
my name is richard kirschner and i'll be
hosting this talk for simply learn
before we start covering the basics of
these three topics and how they connect
and how they are different let's just
look at a few examples so we get an
understanding of what's going on
here's an example of artificial
intelligence in today's world amazon
echo
amazon echo is a wonderful tool we can
go in there and you can say hey alexa
what's the temperature in chicago
and the amazon echo then translates that
into zeros and ones and something the
computer understands
then it comes in and processes that
information to identify what you're
asking and what you need and where to
get that information
and then it comes back and says the
current temperature in chicago is six
degrees fahrenheit or whatever it is at
the moment
so this is a wonderful example of
artificial intelligence that we're using
right now today where that's at as far
as a commercial deployment
machine learning a machine learning
example out there is google you're on
your google search engine it comes up
you spend a lot of time on the first
link you come into and you read the page
and
google looks at that and says okay he
spent five minutes on this let's give it
a thumbs up
and then you go to the second page and
the third page you just kind of skip
over them and glance at them for a
couple seconds and google says i wasn't
interested in those pages let's give
them a thumbs down
so this is a good example of machine
learning as it starts guessing what you
like and what you don't like so it gives
you more information along what you're
going to read and actually use
and then we have an example of deep
learning
uh in this example we have a black and
white image
it comes into in this case a neural
network
some people like to call it a magic box
because you really it's hard to follow
all that's going on in there there's all
these different weights and connections
and nodes
and then it comes out
and colors the beach ball the people the
background
what's going on in here is the black and
white image goes into this neural
network and before it's ever gone in
the neural network has looked at all
these different pictures on the web or
wherever it pulls the data from
and it's already itemized them and kind
of separated them that
we have some that look like beach balls
we have some that look like people and
it programs that so that when the black
and white image comes in it goes okay
that piece right there
resembles this and all these other
photos
and the network is able to identify that
and then color the beach ball with the
colors that you see on there so it gives
it this is really wonderful because they
did a wonderful job coloring this
picture
and that's the full setup is where the
deep learning example comes in and they
usually center around neural networks
so we looked at a few examples what's in
it for you
first we're going to talk about human
versus artificial intelligence
this is very important because this is
our marker we as humans are amazing and
so we want to understand how artificial
intelligence compares
and what it does that it can accelerate
above humans and how it can integrate
with the human experience
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about are they really all
that different
we'll have a few more examples in here
and then we'll talk a little bit about
types of ai and machine learning and
comparing machine learning and deep
learning and finally a glimpse into the
future
human versus artificial intelligence
humans are amazing let's just face it
we're amazing creatures we're all over
the planet we're exploring
every nic chinook we've gone to the moon
we've gone into outer space we're just
amazing creatures
we're able to use the available
information to make decisions to
communicate with other people identify
patterns and data remember what people
have said adapt to new situations so
let's take a look at this so we so you
can get a picture you're a human being
so you know it's like to be human let's
take a look at artificial intelligence
versus the human artificial intelligence
develops computer systems that can
accomplish texts that require human
intelligence
so we're looking at this
one of the things that computers can do
they can provide more accurate results
this is very important
recently i did a project on cancer
whereas identifying markers
and as a human being you look at that
and you might be looking at all the
different images and the data that comes
off of them and say i like this person
so i want to give them a very good
outlook and the next person you might
not like so you want to give a bad
outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're going to get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
as probably the biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we see this
slowly coming in more and more and they
learn from the data and automate
repetitive learning
repetitive learning
has a lot to do with the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there and it's
all automated so as today's computers
evolve it's very quick and easy and
affordable to do this
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us really have a
lot of time anymore to just waste in
today's world
and you're sitting by the road and you
have a whole lot and a whole lot of time
passes by there's a few hours
and suddenly you wonder
how many cars buses trucks and so on
passed by in the six hours
now chances are you're not going to sit
by the road for six hours and count
buses cars and trucks unless you're
working for the city and you're trying
to do city planning and you want to know
hey do we need to add a new truck route
maybe we need a bicycle length we have a
lot of bicyclists here that kind of
thing so maybe city planning would be
great for this
machine learning well the way machine
learning works is we
have labeled data with features
okay so you have a truck or a car a
motorcycle a bus or a bicycle and each
one of those are labeled it comes in and
based on those labels and comparing
those features it gives you an answer
it's a bicycle it's a truck it's a
motorcycle this is a little bit more in
depth on this
and the model here it actually the
features we're looking at would be like
the tires someone sits there and figures
out what a tire looks like it takes a
lot of work if you try to try to figure
the difference between a car tire a
bicycle tire a motorcycle tire
so in the machine learning field this
could take a long time if you're going
to do each individual
aspect of a car
and try to get a result on there and
that's what they did do that was a very
this is still used on smaller amounts of
data where you figure out what those
features are and then you label them
deep learning so with deep learning
one of our solutions is to take a very
large unlabeled data set
and we put that into a training model
using artificial neural networks
and then that goes into the neural
network itself when we create a neural
network and you'll see the arrows are
actually kind of backward but
which actually is a nice point because
when we train the neural network
we put the bicycle in and then it comes
back and says if it's a truck it comes
back and says well you need to change
that to bicycle and then it changes all
those weights going backward they call
it back propagation
and let it know it's a bicycle and
that's how it learns
once you've trained the neural network
you then put the new data in and they
call this testing the model so you need
to have some data you've kept off to the
side where you know the answer to and
you take that and you provide the
required output and you say okay is this
is this neural network working correctly
did it identify a bike as a bike a truck
as a truck a motorcycle as a motorcycle
let's just take a little closer look at
that
determining what objects are present in
the data so how does deep learning do
this and here we have the image of the
bike
it's 28 by 28 pixels that's a lot of
information there could you imagine
trying to guess that this is a bicycle
image by looking at each one of those
pixels and trying to figure out what's
around it
and we actually do that as human beings
it's pretty amazing we know what a
bicycle is and even though it comes in
as all this information
and what this looks like is the image
comes in
it converts it into a bunch of different
nodes in this case there's a lot more
than what they show here and it goes
through these different layers and out
comes and says okay this is a bicycle
a lot of times they call this the magic
black box why because as we watch it go
across here
all these weights
and all the math behind this and it's
not it's a little complicated on the
math side you really don't need to know
that when you're programming or doing
working with the deep learning but it's
like magic you don't know you really
can't figure out what's going to come
out by looking what's in each one of
those dots and each one of those lines
are firing and what's going in between
them so we like to call it the magic box
uh so that's where deep learning comes
in
and in the end it comes up and you have
this whole neural network comes up and
says okay
we fire all these different pixels and
we connects all these different dots
and gives them different weights and
says okay this is a bicycle and that's
how we determine what the object is
present in the data with deep learning
machine learning we're going to take a
step into machine learning here and
you'll see how these fit together in a
minute the system is able to make
predictions or take decisions based on
past data that's very important for
machine learning is that we're
looking at stuff and based on what's
been there before we're creating a
decision on there we're creating
something out of there we're coloring a
beach ball we're telling you what the
weather is
in chicago
what's nice about machine learning is a
very powerful processing capability it's
quick and accurate outcomes
so you get results right away once you
program the system the results are very
fast
and the decisions
and predictions are better they're more
accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data
some of these data things that they're
analyzing now are petabytes and
terabytes of data it would take
hundreds of people
hundreds of years to go through some of
this data and do the same thing that the
machine learning can do in a very short
period of time and it's inexpensive
compared to hiring hundreds of people so
it becomes a very affordable way to move
into the future is to apply the machine
learning
to whatever businesses you're working on
and deep learning systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the more data the deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results
it's scalability so you can scale it up
you can scale it down you can increase
what you're looking at
currently you know we're limited by the
amount of computer processing power as
to how big that can get but that
envelope continually gets pushed every
day on what it can do
problem solved in an end-to-end method
so instead of having to break it apart
and you have the first piece coming in
and you identify tires and the second
piece is identifying
labeling handlebars and then you bring
that together that if it has handlebars
and tires it's a bicycle and if it has
something that looks like a large square
it's probably a truck the neural
networks does this all in one network
you don't really know what's going on in
all those weights and all those little
bubbles
but it does it pretty much in one
package that's why the neural network
systems are so big nowadays and coming
in to their own
best features are selected by the system
and it this is important they kind of
put it's on a bullet on the side here
it's a subset of machine learning this
is important
we talk about deep learning it is a form
of machine learning there's lots of
other forms of machine learning data
analysis but this is the newest and
biggest thing that they apply to a lot
of different packages and they use all
the other machine learning tools
available to work with it and it's very
fast to test
you put in your information
you then have your group of tests
and then you held some aside you see how
does it do it's very quick to test it
and see what's going on with your deep
learning in your neural network
are they really all that different
ai versus machine learning versus deep
learning
concepts of ai
so we have concepts of iii you'll see
natural language processing uh machine
learning an approach to create
artificial intelligence so it's one of
the subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision
robotics
machine learning versus ai versus deep
learning or ai and machine learning and
deep learning
so we look at this we have ai with
machine learning and deep learning
and so we're going to put them all
together we find out that ai is the big
picture we have a collection of books
it goes through some deep learning
the digital data is analyzed text mining
comes through
the particular book you're looking for
maybe it's a genre books is identified
and in this case we have a robot that
goes and gives a book to the patron i
have yet to be at a library that has a
robot bring me a book but that will be
cool when it happens
as we look at some of the pieces here
this information goes into uh there's as
far as this example
the translation of the handwritten
printed data to digital form
that's pretty hard to do that's pretty
hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand
what they're trying to
say
if you've never read them so in this
case we use the deep learning because
you can already use examples where
they've already classified a lot of
books and then they can compare those
texts and say oh okay this is a book on
automotive repair this is a book on
robotic building the digital data is in
analyzed then we have more text mining
using machine learning so maybe we'd use
a different program to do a basic
classify
what you're looking for and say oh
you're looking for
auto repair and computers so you're
looking for automated cars once it's
identified then of course it brings you
the book
so here's a nice summation of what we
were just talking about ai with machine
learning and deep learning deep learning
is a subset of machine learning which is
a subset of artificial intelligence
so you can look at artificial
intelligence as the big picture how does
this compare to the human experience
in either doing the same thing as a
human we do
or it
does it better than us
and machine learning which has a lot of
tools
is something that learns from data past
experiences it's programmed it's uh
comes in there and it says hey we
already had these five things happen the
sixth one should be about the same and
then there's a lot of tools in machine
learning but deep learning then is a
very specific tool in machine learning
it's the artificial neural network which
handles large amounts of data and is
able to take huge pools
of experiences pictures and ideas and
bring them together
real life
examples artificial intelligence news
generation very common nowadays as it
goes through there and finds the news
articles or generates the news based
upon the news feeds
or the back end coming in and says okay
let's give you the actual news based on
this there's all the different things
amazon echo they have a number of
different prime music on there of course
there's also the
google command and there's also
cortana there's tons of smart home
devices now where we can ask it to turn
the tv on or play music for us that's
all artificial intelligence from front
to back
you're having a human experience
with these computers and these
objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning
spam detection very common machine
learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part
so this is the part where it goes and
says okay that's a spam that's not a
spam and it puts it in your spam folder
search engine result refining
another example of machine learning
whereas it looks at your different
results and it go and it is able to
categorize them as far as this had the
most hits this is the least viewed this
has five stars um you know however they
want to weight it
all exactly good examples of machine
learning and then the deep learning uh
deep learning another example is
as you have like a exit sign
in this case is translating it into
french
sorti i hope i said that right
neural network has been programmed with
all these different words and images and
so it's able to look at the exit in the
middle and it goes okay we want to know
what that is in french and it's able to
push that out in france french and learn
how to do that
and then we have chat bots
i remember when microsoft first had
their little paper clip
boy that was like a long time ago they
came up and you would type in there and
chat with it
these are growing you know it's nice to
just be able to ask a question and it
comes up and gives you the answer and
instead of it being were you just doing
a search on certain words it's now able
to start linking those words together
and form a sentence in that chat box
types of ai and machine learning
types of artificial intelligence this in
the next few slides are really important
so one of the types of artificial
intelligence is reactive machines
systems that only react they don't form
memories they don't have past
experiences they have something that
happens to them and they react to it my
washing machine is one of those
if i put a ton of clothes in it and it
all clumped on one side
it automatically adds a weight to
recenter it so that my washing machine
is actually a reactive machine working
with whatever the load is and keeps it
nice and so when it spins it doesn't go
thumping against the side
limited memory another form of
artificial intelligence
systems look into the past
information is added over a period of
time
and information is short-lived
when we're talking about this and you
look at like a neural network that's
been programmed to identify cars
it doesn't remember all those pictures
it has no memory as far as the hundreds
of pictures you process through it all
it has is this is the pattern i use to
identify cars as the final output for
that neural network we looked at
so when they talk about limited memory
this is what they're talking about
they're talking about i've created this
based on all these things but i'm not
going to remember anyone specifically
theory of mind systems being able to
understand human emotions and how they
affect decision making to adjust their
behaviors according to their human
understanding
this is important because this is our
page mark this is how we know
whether it is an artificial intelligence
or not
is it interacting with humans in a way
that we can understand
without that interaction is just an
object so we talk about theory of mind
we really understand how it interfaces
that whole if you're in web development
user experience would be the term i
would put in there so the theory of mind
would be user experience how's the whole
ui connected together and one of the
final things is as we get into
artificial intelligence is systems being
aware of themselves
understanding their internal states and
predicting other people's feelings and
act appropriately so as artificial
intelligence continues to progress uh we
see ones that are trying to understand
well what makes people happy how would
they increase our happiness
how would they keep themselves from
breaking down if something's broken
inside they have that self-awareness to
be able to fix it and just based on all
that information
predicting which action would work the
best what would help people
if i know that you're having a cup of
coffee first thing in the morning is
what makes you happy as a robot i might
make you a cup of coffee every morning
at the same time
to help your life and help you grow
that'd be the self-awareness is being
able to know all those different things
types of machine learning and like i
said on the last slide this is very
important this is very important if you
decide to go in and get certified in
machine learning or know more about it
these are the three primary types of
machine learning
the first one is supervised learning
systems are able to predict future
outcome based on past data requires both
an input and an output to be given to
the model for it to be trained
so in this case we're looking at
anything where you have a hundred images
of a bicycle
and those hundred images you know are
bicycle so their presets someone already
looked at all hundred images and said
these are pictures of bicycles and so
the computer learns from those and then
it's given another picture
and maybe the next picture is a bicycle
and it says oh that resembles all these
other bicycles so it's a bicycle
and the next one's a car and it says
that's not a bicycle
that would be supervised learning
because we had to train it we had to
supervise it unsupervised learning
systems are able to identify hidden
patterns from the input data provided by
making the data more readable and
organized the patterns similarities or
anomalies become more evident you'll
heard the term cluster how do you
cluster things together some of these
things go together some of these don't
this is unsupervised where you can look
at an image and start pulling the
different pieces of the image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them just
slightly out of focus which is not the
same as the beach ball it's unsupervised
because we never told it what a beach
ball was we never told them what the
human was and we never told it that
those were trees
all we told it was hey separate this
picture by things that don't match
and things that do match and come
together
and finally there's reinforcement
learning systems are given no training
it learns on the basis of the reward
punishment it received for performing
its last action it helps increase the
efficiency of a tool function or a
program reinforced learning a
reinforcement learning is kind of you
give it a yes or no yes you gave me the
right response no you didn't and then it
looks at that and says oh okay so based
on this data coming in
what i gave you was a wrong response so
next time i'll give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools and so they
we're grouping a ton of machine learning
tools all together linear regression k
means clustering there's all kinds of
cool tools out there you can use in
machine learning enables machines to
take decisions to make decisions on
their own based on past data
enables machines to make decisions with
the help of artificial neural networks
so it's doing the same thing but we're
using an artificial neural network as
opposed to one of the more traditional
machine learning tools
needs only a small amount of training
data this is very important when you're
talking about machine learning
they're usually not talking about huge
amounts of data we're talking about
maybe your spreadsheet from your
business and your totals for the end of
the year when you're talking about
neural networks you usually need a large
amount of data to train the data so
there's a lot of training involved if
you have under 500 points of data that's
probably
not going to go into machine learning or
maybe you have like the case of one of
the things 500 points of data and 30
different fields
it starts getting really confusing there
in artificial intelligence or machine
learning and the deep learning aspect
really shines when you get to that
larger data that's really complex
works well on a low end systems
so a lot of the machine learning tools
out there you can run on your laptop
with no problem and do the calculations
there
where with the machine learning usually
needs a higher end system to work it
takes a lot more processing power to
build those neural networks and to train
them it goes through a lot of data
we're talking about the general machine
learning tools most features need to be
identified in advanced and manually
coded so there's a lot of human work on
here
the machine learns the features from the
data it is provided so again it's like a
magic box you don't have to know what a
tire is
it figures it out for you
the problem is divided into parts and
solved individually and then combined so
machine learning you usually have all
these different tools and use different
tools for different parts
and the problem is solved in an
end-to-end manner so you only have one
neural network or two neural networks
that is bringing the data in and putting
it out it's not going through a lot of
different processes to get there and
remember you can put machine learning
and deep learning together so you don't
always have
just the deep learning solving the
problem by having selling one piece of
the puzzle
with regular machine learning and most
machine learning tools out there they
take longer to test and understand how
they work
and with the deep learning it's pretty
quick once you build that neural network
you test it and you know
so we're dealing with very crisp rules
limited resources
you have to really explain how the
decision was made when you use most
machine learning tools but when you use
the deep learning tool inside the
machine learning tools
the system takes care of it based on its
own logic and reasoning and again it's
like a magic black box
you really don't know how it came up
with the answer you just know it came up
with the right answer a glimpse into the
future
so a quick glimpse into the future
artificial intelligence be using it to
detecting crimes before they happen
humanoid ai helpers which we already
have a lot of there'll be more and more
maybe it'll actually be androids that'd
be cool to have an android that comes
and get stuff out of my fridge for me
machine learning increasing efficiency
in healthcare that's really big in all
the forms of machine learning better
marketing techniques
any of these things if we get into the
sciences it's just off the scale machine
learning and artificial intelligence go
everywhere and then the subcategory deep
learning increased personalization so
what's really nice about the deep
learning is it's going to start now
catering to you that'll be one of the
things we see more and more of
and we'll have more of a hyper
intelligent personal assistant i'm
excited about that machine learning has
improved our lives in a number of
wonderful ways today let's talk about
some of these i'm rahul from simply
learn and these are the top 10
applications of machine learning first
let's talk about virtual personal
assistants google assistant alexa
cortana and siri now we've all used one
of these at least at some point in our
lives now these help improve our lives
in a great number of ways for example
you could tell them to call someone you
could tell them to play some music you
could tell them to even schedule an
appointment so how do these things
actually work first they record whatever
you're saying send it over to a server
which is usually in a cloud decode it
with the help of machine learning in
neural networks and then provide you
with an output so if you ever notice
that these systems don't work very well
without the internet that's because the
server couldn't be contacted next let's
talk about traffic predictions now say i
wanted to travel from buckingham palace
to large cricket ground the first thing
i would probably do is to get on google
maps so
search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue but the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there the yellow indicate that
they're slightly congested and red means
they're heavily congested so let's look
at the map a different version of the
same map and here as i told you before
red means heavily congested yellow means
slow moving and blue means clear
so how exactly is google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real-time
location data of vehicles from google
maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
bing maps maps dot me and here we go
next up we have social media
personalization so say i want to buy a
drone and i'm on amazon and i want to
buy a dji mavic pro the thing is it's
close to one lap so i don't want to buy
it right now but the next time i'm on
facebook i'll see an advertisement for
the product next time i'm on youtube
i'll see an advertisement even on
instagram i'll see an advertisement so
here with the help of machine learning
google has understood that i'm
interested in this particular product
hence it's targeting me with these
advertisements this is also with the
help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so gmail has an entire collection of
emails which have already been labeled
as spam or not spam so after analyzing
this data gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that gmail uses is content
filters header filters general blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes that it would
cause with the hash values stock market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to stock
market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long
short-term memory neural networks now
these are used to classify process and
predict datum when there are time lags
of unknown size and duration now this is
used to predict stock market trends
assistive medical technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3d models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and ischemic stroke lesions they
can also be used in fetal imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're a foreign country and you
see billboards and signs that you don't
understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chat
bots here the image recognition happens
using convolutional neural networks and
the text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequence to sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other there are many
interesting machine learning algorithms
let's have a look at a few of them
hopefully this gives you a little flavor
of what's out there and these are some
of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support vector machine
let's start with a closer look at linear
regression linear regression is perhaps
one of the most well-known and
well-understood algorithms in statistics
and machine learning linear regression
is a linear model for example a model
that assumes a linear relationship
between the input variables x and the
single output variable y and you'll see
this if you remember from your algebra
classes y equals mx plus c imagine we
are predicting distance traveled y from
speed x our linear regression model
representation for this problem would be
y equals m times x plus c or distance
equals m times speed plus c where m is
the coefficient and c is the y-intercept
and we're going to look at two different
variations of this first we're going to
start with time is constant and you can
see we have a bicyclist he's got a
safety gear on thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second and so
over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers we have a
second bicyclist it's going twice the
speed or 20 meters per second and you
can guess if he's going twice the speed
and time is a constant then he's going
to go twice the distance and that's easy
to compute 36 times 2 you get 72
kilometers and so if you had the
question of
how fast would somebody is going three
times that speed or 30 meters per second
is you can easily compute the distance
in our head we can do that without
needing a computer but we want to do
this for more complicated data so it's
kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed and we have
our m equals the ve slope of the line
and we'll notice that the line has a
plus slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals mx plus c distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing it's
3 times 10 meters per second that this
is roughly 102 kilometers distance that
this third bicyclist has traveled one of
the key
definitions on here is positive
relationship so the slope of the line is
positive as distance increase so to
speed increase let's take a look at our
second example where we put distance is
a constant so we have speed equals 10
meters per second they have a certain
distance to go and it takes them 100
seconds to travel that distance and we
have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 meters per second since he's
going twice the speed we can guess that
he'll cover the distance in about half
the time 50 seconds and of course you
could probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed you can easily guess
that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or graph if the
distance is assumed to be constant let's
see the relationship between speed and
time and as time goes up the amount of
speed to go that same distance goes down
so now your m equals a minus ve slope of
the line as the speed increases time
decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship depended on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see what the mathematical
implementation of linear regression and
we'll take this data so suppose we have
this data set where we have x y x equals
1 2 3 4 5 standard series and the y
value is 3 2 2 4 3. when we take that
and we go ahead and plot these points on
a graph you can see there's kind of a
nice scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression and the first
thing we do is we come up here we have
the mean of x i and remember mean is
basically the average so we added five
plus four plus three plus two plus one
and divide by five and that simply comes
out as three and then we'll do the same
for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of i
equals 2.8 where the x i references it's
an average or means value and the y i
also equals a means value of y and when
we plot that you'll see that we can put
in the y equals 2.8 and the x equals 3
in there on our graph we kind of give it
a little different color so you can sort
it out with the dashed lines on it and
it's important to note that when we do
the linear regression the linear
regression model should go through that
dot now let's find our regression
equation to find the best fit line
remember we go ahead and take our y
equals mx plus c so we're looking for m
and c so to find this equation for our
data we need to find our slope of m and
our coefficient of c
and we have y equals mx plus c
where m equals the sum of x minus x
average times y minus y average or y
means and x means over the sum of x
minus x means squared that's how we get
the slope of the value of the line and
we can easily do that by creating some
columns here we have x y computers are
really good about iterating through data
and so we can easily compute this and
fill in a graph of data and in our graph
you can easily see that if we have our x
value of 1 and if you remember the x i
or the means value is 3 1 minus 3 equals
a negative 2 and 2 minus 3 equals a
negative 1 so on and so forth and we can
easily fill in the column of x minus x i
y minus y i and then from those we can
compute x minus x i squared and x minus
x i times y minus y i and you can guess
it that the next step is to go ahead and
sum the different columns for the
answers we need so we get a total of 10
for our x minus x i squared and a total
of 2 for x minus x i times y minus y i
and we plug those in we get 2 10 which
equals 0.2 so now we know the slope of
our line equals 0.2 so we can calculate
the value of c that'd be the next step
is we need to know where it crosses the
y axis and if you remember i mentioned
earlier that the linear regression line
has to pass through
the means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph and you can see right here
there's our means value which is 3 x
equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value we can simply plug that
into our formula y equals 0.2 x plus c
so we plug that in we get 2.8 equals 0.2
times 3 plus c and you can just solve
for c so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line y equals 0.2 times x
plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute new values so let's predict
the values of y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5
and plot the points remember the 1 2 3 4
5 was our original x values so now we're
going to see what y thinks they are not
what they actually are and we plug those
in we get y of designated with y of p
you can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6 and so on and so on
so we have our y predicted values of
what we think it's going to be when we
plug those numbers in and when we plot
the predicted values along with the
actual values we can see the difference
and this is one of the things that's
very important with linear aggression in
any of these models is to understand the
error
and so we can calculate the error on all
of our different values and you can see
over here we plotted x and y and y
predict and we've drawn a little line so
you can sort of see what the error looks
like there between the different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error etc we keep moving this
line through the data points to make
sure the best fit line has the least
square distance between the data points
and the regression line so to recap with
a very simple linear regression model we
first figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals mx plus c but you
can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those using
the different formulas to minimize the
error let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model decision tree is a tree-shaped
algorithm used to determine a course of
action each branch of a tree represents
a possible decision occurrence or
reaction we have data which tells us if
it is a good day to play golf and if we
were to open this data up in a general
spreadsheet you can see we have the
outlook whether it's a rainy overcast
sunny temperature
hot mild cool humidity windy and did i
like to play golf that day yes or no so
we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not but you
could imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would be fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next uh whatever you
know next meal out in this case is
tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in and so we
come up and let's determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our normal which is if it's
if you have a normal humidity you're
going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the outlook and if the outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf because you're going to be out
there miserable fighting off the
mosquitoes that are out joining you to
play golf with you maybe if it's raining
you probably don't want to play in the
rain but if it's slightly overcast you
get just the right
shadow that's a good day to play golf
and be outside out on the green now in
this example you can probably make your
own tree pretty easily because it's a
very simple set of data going in but the
question is how do you know what to
split where do you split your data what
if this is much more complicated data
where it's not something that you would
particularly understand like studying
cancer they take about 36 measurements
of the cancerous cells and then each one
of those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but since the question is going to
come up is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information gain two important
vocabulary words there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or impurity
in the data set entropy should be low so
we want the chaos to be as low as
possible we don't want to look at it and
be confused by the images or what's
going on there with mixed data and the
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
information gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side in this case we're
going to denote entropy as i of p of and
n where p
is the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and n is the
probability where you're not going to
play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log squared of p over p plus n minus n
over p plus n times the log squared of n
of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like when
we're computing that from the computer
script side
entropy of a target class of the data
set is the whole entropy so we have
entropy play golf and we look at this if
we go back to the data you can simply
count how many yeses and no in our
complete data set for playing golf days
in our complete set we find we have five
days we did play golf and nine days we
did not play golf and so our i equals if
you had those together nine plus five is
fourteen and so our i equals five over
fourteen and nine over fourteen that's
our p and n values that we plug into
that formula and you can go to five over
fourteen equals point three six nine
over fourteen equals point six four and
when you do the whole equation you get
the minus 0.36 log root squared of 0.36
minus 0.64 log squared root of 0.64 and
we get a set value we get 0.94
so we now have a full entropy value for
the whole set of data that we're working
with and we want to make that entropy go
down and just like we calculated the
entropy out for the whole set we can
also calculate entropy for playing golf
and the outlook is it going to be
overcast or rainy or sunny and so we
look at the entropy we have p of sunny
times e of 3 of 2 and that just comes
out how many sunny days yes and how many
sunny days no over the total which is 5.
don't forget to put the we'll divide
that five out later on equals p overcast
equals four comma zero plus rainy equals
two comma three and then when you do the
whole setup we have five over fourteen
remember i said there was a total of
five five over fourteen times the i of
three of two plus four over fourteen
times the four comma zero and five
fourteen over i of two three and so we
can now compute the entropy of just the
part it has to do with the forecast and
we get 0.693 similarly we can calculate
the entropy of other predictors like
temperature humidity and wind and so we
look at the gain outlook how much are we
going to gain from this entropy play
golf minus entropy play golf outlook and
we can take the original 0.94 for the
whole set minus the entropy of just the
rainy day and temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy and we define an
information gain the higher the
information gain the lower the entropy
the better the information gain of the
other three attributes can be calculated
in the same way so we have our gain for
temperature equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152 and our gain for a windy day
equals 0.048 and if you do a quick
comparison you'll see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest information
gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
information gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our outlook we split it three
different directions if the outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go outlook sunny outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smartwatch pops up and says i'm
sorry tomorrow is not a good day for
golf it's going to be sunny and windy
and if you're a huge golf fan you might
go uh-oh
it's not a good day to play golf we can
go in and watch a golf game at home so
we'll sit in front of the tv instead of
being out playing golf in the wind
now that we've looked at our decision
tree let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
vector machine support vector machine is
a widely used classification algorithm
the idea of support vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females
a new data point arrives and we want to
know whether it's going to be a male or
a female so we start by drawing a line
we draw decision lines but if we
consider decision line one that we will
classify the individual as a male and if
we consider decision line two then it
will be a female so you can see this
person kind of lies in the middle of the
two groups so it's a little confusing
trying to figure out which line they
should be under we need to know which
line divides the classes correctly but
how the goal is to choose a hyperplane
and that is one of the key words they
use when we talk about support vector
machines choose a hyperplane with the
greatest possible margin between the
decision line and the nearest point
within the training set
so you can see here we have our support
vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyperplane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equal the distance between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line one has a maximum
distance margin so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and our result
on this one is going to be that the new
data point is mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line
is that a lot of times we're not looking
at just weight and height we might be
looking at 36 different features or
dimensions and so when we cut it with a
hyperplane it's more of a
three-dimensional cut in the data
multi-dimensional it cuts the data a
certain way and each plane continues to
cut it down until we get the best fit or
match let's understand this with the
help of an example problem statement i
always start with a problem statement
when you're going to put some code
together we're going to do some coding
now classifying muffin and cupcake
recipes using support vector machines so
the cupcake versus the muffin let's have
a look at our data set and we have the
different recipes here we have a muffin
recipe that has so much flour i'm not
sure what measurement 55 is in but it
has 55 maybe it's ounces
but has a certain amount of flour
certain amount of milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and so
based on these measurements we want to
guess whether we're making a muffin or a
cupcake and you can see in this one we
don't have just two features we don't
just have height and weight as we did
before between the male and female in
here we have a number of features
in fact in this we're looking at eight
different features to guess whether it's
a muffin or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake turns out muffins have
more flour while cupcakes have more
butter and sugar so basically the
cupcake's a little bit more of a dessert
where the muffins a little bit more of a
fancy bread but how do we do that in
python how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is and i really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
start in our cupcakes versus muffins we
are going to be working in python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda and jupiter notebook the
anaconda navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anaconda
navigator you can change environments i
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python36
environment so this is in python version
3.6 although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use i usually try to
stay with the 3x because they're current
unless you have a project that's very
specifically in version 2x 27 i think is
usually what most people use in the
version 2. and then once we're in our
jupiter notebook editor i can go up and
create a new file and we'll just jump in
here
in this case we're doing svm
muffin versus cupcake and then let's
start with our packages
for data analysis
and we almost always use a couple
there's a few very standard packages we
use
we use
import import import
numpy that's for number python they
usually denote it as np that's very
comma
that's very common
and then we're going to import pandas as
pd
and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy setup
as far as multiplying all the values in
an array in a numpy array data array
pandas
i can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set i think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is that a data frame
is more like your excel spreadsheet you
have columns you have indexes you have
different ways of referencing it easily
viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so they you
need them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support vector machine so
from sk learn we're going to use the sk
learn model
import svm support vector machine
and then
as a data scientist you should always
try to visualize your data some data
obviously is too complicated or doesn't
make any sense to the human but if it's
possible it's good to take a second look
at it so you can actually see what
you're doing now for that we're going to
use two packages we're going to import
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt
again very common
and we're going to import seaborn as sns
and we'll go ahead and set the font
scale in the sns right in our import
line that's what this
semicolon followed by a line of data
we're going to set the sns and these are
great because the the seaborn sits on
top of map plot library just like pandas
hits on numpy so it adds a lot more
features and uses and control we're
obviously not going to get into matplot
library and seabourn would be its own
tutorial
we're really just focusing on the svm
the support vector machine from sk learn
and since we're in jupiter notebook
we have to add a special line in here
for our matplot library and that's your
percentage sign or ambersign matplot
library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code project a lot of times i
use like notepad plus plus and i'll run
it from there you don't have to have
that line in there because it'll just
pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your
computer's set up because we're running
this in the jupyter notebook as a
browser setup this tells it to display
all of our graphics right below on the
page so that's what that line is for i
remember the first time i ran this i
didn't know that i had to go look that
up years ago it's quite a headache so
matplot library inline is just because
we're running this on the web setup and
we can go ahead and run this make sure
all our modules are in they're all
imported which is great if you don't
have an import you'll need to go ahead
and pip use the pip or however you do it
there's a lot of other install packages
out there although pip is the most
common and you have to make sure these
are all installed on your python setup
the next step of course is we got to
look at the data you can't run a model
for predicting data if you don't have
actual data so to do that let me go and
open this up and take a look and we have
our cupcakes versus muffins
and it's a csv file or dot csv meaning
that it's comma separated variable
and it's going to open it up in a nice
spreadsheet for me and you can see up
here we have the type we have muffin
muffin muffin cupcake cupcake cupcake
and then it's broken up into flour milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt
so we can do is we can go ahead and look
at this data also in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module
dot read
csv remember is a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus muffins oops i got
double brackets there
do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program i loaded or the the
place i saved this particular python
program is in the same folder we get by
with just the file name but remember if
you're storing it in a different
location you have to also put down the
full path on there
and then because we're in pandas
we're going to go ahead and you can
actually inline you can do this but let
me do the full print you can just type
in
recipes dot head in the jupiter notebook
but if you're running in code in a
different script you need to go ahead
and type out the whole print recipes dot
head
and panda's nose is that's going to do
the first five lines of data and if we
flip back on over to the spreadsheet
where we opened up our csv file
uh you can see where it starts on line
two this one calls it zero and then
two three four five six is going to
match
go and close that out because we don't
need that anymore
and it always starts at zero and these
are it automatically indexes it since we
didn't tell it to use an index in here
so that's the index number for the left
hand side and it automatically took the
top row
as labels so pandas
using it to read a csv is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas
not just because they're cute and cuddly
teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data
and i'm not going to plot all of it i'm
just going to plot the
sugar and flower
now obviously
you can see where they get really
complicated if we have tons of different
features and so you'll break them up and
maybe look at just two of them at a time
to see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use seaborne
so that's our sns
and the command for that is sns.lm
and then the two different variables i'm
going to plot is flour and sugar
data equals recipes
the hue equals type
and this is a lot of fun because it
knows that this is pandas coming in
so this is one of the powerful things
about pandas mixed with seaborne and
doing
graphing
and then we're going to use a palette
set one there's a lot of different sets
in there you can go look them up for
seabourn or do a regular fit regular
equals false so we're not really trying
to fit anything
and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you look up in
seabourn half these you could probably
leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a seaborn plot
let's go ahead and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on sugar and flour alone
there's a definite split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at and say hey if i drew a
line right between the middle of the
blue dots and the red dots we'd be able
to do an svm and a hyperplane right
there in the middle
then the next step is to
format or pre-process
our data
and we're going to break that up into
two parts
we need a type
label and remember we're going to decide
whether it's a muffin or cupcake well a
computer doesn't know muffin or cupcake
it knows zero and one
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a type label
from this we'll create a numpy array
and p
where
and this is where we can do some logic
we take our recipes from our panda
and whatever type equals muffin it's
going to be zero and then if it doesn't
equal muffin which is cupcakes it's
going to be 1. so we create our type
label
this is the answer so when we're doing
our training model remember we have to
have a training data this is what we're
going to train it with is that it's 0 or
1. it's a muffin or it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features
and if you remember correctly from right
up here the first column is type
so we really don't need the type columns
that's our muffin or cupcake
and in pandas we can easily sort that
out
we take our value recipes
dot
columns that's a pandas function built
into pandas
got values converting them to values so
it's just the column titles going across
the top
and we don't want the first one so what
we do is since it always starts at zero
we want one
colon till the end
and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to a list of
strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features make sure it looks right
let me go ahead and run that
and i forgot the s on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flour
milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and that
matches what we have up here right where
we printed out everything but the type
so we have our features and we have our
label
now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns and we actually
need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're doing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients
we have you know that's what uh
seven eight different hyper planes that
would be built into it we only want to
look at one so you can see what the svm
is doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just flour and sugar
again you can replace that with your
recipe features and do all of them but
we're going to do just flour and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values
we don't need to make a list out of it
because it's not string values these are
actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients and you can see what that
looks like
and so we have just the amount of flour
and sugar just the two sets of plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here and
take our recipe features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features you'll see that it makes
a nice column of different data so it
just strips out all the labels and
everything we just have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a plot later on we'll go
ahead and take that and just do flour
and sugar
and we'll run that you'll see it's just
the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model
we'll go ahead and just call it model
and it's a svm
we're using a package called svc
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the svm
you'll see that there's about there's
eight of them here
three of them are for regression
three are for classification the svc
support vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and there's also one for detecting
outliers
and another one that has to do with
something a little bit more specific on
the model but svc and sbr are the two
most commonly used standing for support
vector classifier and support vector
regression remember regression is an
actual value a float value or
whatever you're trying to work on and
sbc is a classifier so it's a yes no
true false
but for this we want to know zero one
muffin cupcake
if we go ahead and create our model and
once we have our model created we're
gonna do model.fit and this is very
common especially in the sklearn all
their models are followed with the fit
command and what we put into the fit
what we're training with it is we're
putting in the ingredients which in this
case we limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
whether you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that it gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data
and let's go ahead and run this and now
we have our model fit
and i got an error here so let me fix
that real quick
capital sbc it turns out
i did it lowercase
support vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically
these are the defaults of the model
you notice that we change the kernel to
linear and there's our kernel linear on
the printout and there's other different
settings you can mess with
we're going to just leave that alone for
right now for this we don't really need
to mess with any of those
so next we're going to dig a little bit
into our newly trained model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a graph
and let's go ahead and get the
separating
and we're going to see we're going to
use a w for our variable on here
we're going to do model
dot coefficient underscore 0.
so what the heck is that again we're
digging into the model so we've already
got a prediction and a train
this is the math behind it that we're
looking at right now
and so
the w is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y equals mx plus c so
these coefficients are connected to that
but in two-dimensional it's a plane
we don't spend
too much time on this because you can
get lost in the confusion of the math so
if you're a math whiz this is great you
can go through here and you'll see that
we have a equals minus w0 over w of one
remember there's two different values
there
and that's basically
the slope that we're generating
and then we're going to build an xx what
is xx we're going to set it up to a
numpy array there's our np dot line
space so we're creating a line
of values between 30 and 60. so it just
creates a set of numbers for x
and then if you remember correctly we
have
our formula y equals the slope times x
plus the intercept
well to make this work we can do this as
y y
equals the slope times each value in
that array that's a neat thing about
numpy so when i do a times x x which is
a whole numpy array of values it
multiplies a across all of them
and then it takes those same values and
we subtract the model intercept that's
your uh
where we had mx plus c so that'd be the
c from the formula y equals mx plus
c and that's where all these numbers
come from a little bit confusing because
it's digging out of these different
arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane that passed through the
support vectors
and so we're going to create b equals a
model
support vectors
pulling our support vectors out there
here's our y y which we now know is a
set of data and we have we're going to
create yy down
equals a times x plus
b1 minus a times b0
and then model support vector b
is going to be set that to a new value
the minus 1 set up and yy up equals a
times x plus b1 minus a times b0
and we go ahead and just run this to
load these variables up if you wanted to
know understand a little bit more of
what's going on you can see if we print
y y let me just run that
you can see it's an array this is a line
it's going to have in this case between
30 and 60 so it's going to be 30
variables in here
and the same thing with y y up yy down
and we'll we'll plot those in just a
minute on the graph so you can see what
those look like
just go ahead and delete that out of
here
and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate
i'm just going to copy this from before
remember this our sns
our seaborn plot lm plot flower sugar
and i'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the new things is
because seaborn sits on top of pie plot
we can do the pie plot for the line
going through and that is simply plt dot
plot
and that's our xx and yy our two
corresponding values x y
and then somebody played with this to
figure out that the line width equals
two in the color black would look nice
so let's go ahead and run this whole
thing with the pie plot on there
and you can see when we do this it's
just doing flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flour and the muffin versus cupcake
and then we generated the support
vectors the yy down and yy out so let's
take a look and see what that looks like
so we'll do our pl plot
and again this is all against x
our x value but this time we have y y
down
and let's do something a little fun with
this
we can put in a k
dash dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line
and if we're going to do the down one
we also want to do the up one
so here's our yy
up
and when we run that it
both sets of line
and so here's our support and this is
what you expect you expect these two
lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dashed lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour
which one's a muffin or a cupcake
let's go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
i've got my
recipes i pulled off the
internet and i want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through and create
a function with depth
and let's call it muffin or cupcake and
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients to know it's flour
and sugar
and let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if model predict
is of flour and sugar equals zero
so we take our model and we do it run a
predict it's very common in sk learn we
have a dot predict you put the data in
and it's going to return a value in this
case if it equals zero then print you're
looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for
function or def for definition d e f is
how you do that in python
and of course we're going to create a
function you should run something in it
and so let's run a cupcake and we're
going to send it values 50 and 20 a
muffin or cupcake i don't know what it
is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us
and it says oh it's a muffin you're
looking at a muffin recipe
so it very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake recipe
let's
plot this
there we go plot this on the graph so we
can see what that actually looks like
and i'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there
so this is nothing different than we did
before if i run it
you'll see it has all the points and the
lines on there and what we want to do is
we want to add another point
and we'll do plt plot
and if you remember correctly we did for
our test we did 50
and 20.
and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do a y-o for yellow or
it's kind of a oranges yellow color it's
going to come out marker size nine those
are settings you can play with somebody
else played with them to come up with
the right setup so it looks good and you
can see there it is graphed
clearly a muffin
in this case in cupcakes versus muffins
the muffin has won
and if you'd like to do your own muffin
cupcake contender series you certainly
can send a note down below and the team
at learn will send you over the data
they use for the muffin and cupcake and
that's true of any of the data we didn't
actually run a plot on it earlier we had
min versus women
you can also request that information to
run it on your data setup so you can
test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support vector machine
code we did a predict 40 parts flower 20
parts sugar i think it was different
than the one we did whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake hence we have built
a classifier using svm which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin
what's in it for you we're going to
cover clustering what is clustering k
means clustering which is one of the
most common used clustering tools out
there including a flow chart to
understand k-means clustering and how it
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on brands then we're going to
cover logistic regression what is
logistic regression logistic regression
curve and sigmoid function and then
we'll do another python code demo to
classify a tumor as malignant or benign
based on features
and let's start with clustering suppose
we have a pile of books of different
genres now we divide them into different
groups like fiction horror education and
as we can see from this young lady she
definitely is into heavy horror you can
just tell by those eyes and the maple
canadian leaf on her shirt but we have
fiction horror and education and we want
to go ahead and divide our books up well
organizing objects into groups based on
similarity is clustering and in this
case as we're looking at the books we're
talking about clustering things with
known categories but you can also use it
to explore data so you might not know
the categories you just know that you
need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case we're going to
be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use k means
clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library k-means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to cluster to different
groups define clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data some of that information
isn't so easy to see right when we first
look at it and so k-means is one of
those tools where we can start finding
things that connect that match with each
other suppose we have these data points
and want to assign them into a cluster
now when i look at these data points i
would probably group them into two
clusters just by looking at them i'd say
two of these group of data kind of come
together but in k-means we pick k
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the k clusters represents
two different clusters we pick k
clusters and cyrano centroids to the
clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances
and calculate the centroids so we figure
out what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stop changing their
positions and become static
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stop changing
and the positions become static once the
clusters become static then k means
clustering algorithm is said to be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math we're
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or it's converged on an
answer so we see the flow chart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy step by
step so we start we choose k we'll look
at the elbow method in just a moment we
assign random centroids to clusters and
sometimes you pick the centroids because
you might look at the data in a graph
and say oh these are probably the
central points then we compute the
distance from the objects to the
centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids then we compute the
distance from objects to the new
centroids and then we go back and repeat
those last two steps we calculate the
distances so as we're doing it brings
into the new centroid and then we move
the centroid around and we figure out
what the best which objects are closest
to each centroid so the objects can
switch from one centroid to the other
the centroids are moved around and we
continue that until it is converged
let's see an example of this
suppose we have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics a and b so here's our subject
in this case referring to the person
taking the test
and then we have subject a where we see
what they've scored on their first
subject and we have subject b and we can
see what they score on the second
subject now let's take two farthest
apart points as initials cluster
centroids remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it
so we took the two furthest points one
and one and five and seven and now let's
take the two farthest apart points as
initial cluster centroids each point is
then assigned to the closest cluster
with respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measure each
of those distances and you use the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the x and the
y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster the centroid then
moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3 so
remember was that one and one well the
very center of the data we're looking at
would put it at the one point roughly 2
2 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the second one if
we wanted to make the overall mean
vector the average vector of all the
different distances to that centroid we
come up with four comma one and five
four so we've now moved the centroids we
compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean and to that of the
opposite cluster and we find build a
nice chart on here that the as we move
the centroid around we now have a new
different kind of clustering of groups
and using euclidean distance between the
points and the mean we get the same
formula you see these new formulas
coming up so we have our individual dots
distance to the mean centroid of the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster
only individual three is nearer to the
mean of the opposite cluster cluster two
than its own cluster one and you can see
here in the diagram where we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster the centroids of
the clusters over one of the points
shifted to the other cluster because
it's closer to that group of individuals
thus individual 3 is relocated to
cluster 2 resulting in a new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here on comparing the
distance of each individual's distance
to its own cluster mean and to that of
the opposite cluster we find that the
data points are stable hence we have our
final clusters now if you remember i
brought up a concept earlier caming on
the k-means algorithm choosing the right
value of k will help in less number of
iterations and to find the appropriate
number of clusters in a data set we use
the elbow method and within sum of
squares wss is defined as the sum of the
squared distance between each member of
the cluster in its centroid and so you
see we've done here is we have the
number of clusters and as you do
the same k-means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
find the optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow the graph is called as the elbow
method and on this we guessed it two
just by looking at the data but as you
can see
the slope you actually just look for
right there where the elbow is in the
slope and you have a clear answer that
we want two different to start with k
means equals two a lot of times people
end up computing k-means equals two
three four five until they find the
value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain i
mentioned that last time you'll know
that where to pick those numbers or
where to start guessing at what that k
value is so let's take this and we're
going to use a use case using k-means
clustering to cluster cars into brands
using parameters such as horsepower
cubic inches make year etc so we're
going to use the data set cars data
having information about three brands of
cars toyota honda and nissan we'll go
back to my favorite tool the anaconda
navigator with the jupiter notebook and
let's go ahead and flip over to our
jupiter notebook and in our jupiter
notebook i'm going to go ahead and just
paste the basic
code that we usually start a lot of
these off with we're not going to go too
much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
they'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame and map plot
for the graphing and don't forget uh
since if you're using the jupiter
notebook you do need the map plot
library inline so that it plots
everything on the screen if you're using
a different python editor then you
probably don't need that because it'll
have a pop-up window on your computer
we'll go ahead and run this just to load
our libraries and our setup into here
the next step is of course to look at
our data which i've already opened up in
a spreadsheet and you can see here we
have the miles per gallon cylinders
cubic inches horsepower weight pounds
how you know how heavy it is time it
takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90. what year it is so this is you
can actually see this is kind of older
cars and then the brand toyota
honda nissan so the different cars are
coming from all the way from 1971 if we
scroll down
to the 80s we have between the 70s and
80s the number of cars that they've put
out
and let's uh we come back here we're
going to importing the data so we'll go
ahead and do data set equals and we'll
use pandas to read this in and it's uh
from a csv file remember you can always
post this in the comments and request
the data files for these either in the
comments here on the youtube video or go
to simplylearn.com and request that the
car csv i put it in the same folder as
the code that i've stored so my python
code is stored in the same folder so i
don't have to put the full path if you
store them in different folders you do
have to change this and double check
your name variables and we'll go ahead
and run this and we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because it's a data set
we're importing and we've now imported
our car csv into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the x data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there's a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
four i
and x dot columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns
and a lot of times it's important
i'll make lists of the columns and do
this because i might remove certain
columns or there might be columns that i
want to be processed differently but for
this we can go ahead and take x of i
and we want to go fill in a and that's a
pandas command but the question is what
are we going to fill the missing data
with we definitely don't want to just
put in a number that doesn't actually
mean something and so one of the tricks
you can do with this
is we can take x of i and in addition to
that we want to go ahead and turn this
into
an integer because a lot of these are
integers so we'll go ahead and keep it
integers and let me add the bracket here
and a lot of editors will do this
they'll think that you're closing one
bracket make sure you get that second
bracket in there if it's a double
bracket that's always something that
happens regularly so once we have our
integer of x of y this is going to fill
in any missing data with the average
and i was so busy closing one set of
brackets i forgot that the mean is also
has brackets in there for the pandas so
we can see here we're going to fill in
all the data with the average value for
that column so there's missing data is
in the average of the data it does have
then once we've done that we'll go ahead
and loop through it again
and just check and see
to make sure everything is filled in
correctly and we'll print and then we
take x
is null and this returns a set of the
null value or the how many lines are
null and we'll just sum that up to see
what that looks like and so when i run
this
and so with the x what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because that had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out for one we could take the x
and we could go data set our variable
we're using and use the i location one
of the features that's in pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows and all but the last column of
the data set
and at this time we could do values we
just convert it to values so that's one
way to do this and if i let me just put
this down here and print
x
it's a capital x we chose and i run this
you can see it's just the values
we could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what i like to do with this
is instead of doing the i location which
does integers more common is to come in
here and we have our data set
and we're going to do data set
dot or data set dot columns and remember
that lists all the columns so if i come
in here
let me just mark that as red
and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data columns of everything but
the last one minus one so now if i print
this you'll see the brand disappears
and so i can actually just take
data set columns minus one
and i'll put it right in here for the
columns we're going to look at
and let's un mark this
and unmark
this
and now if i do an x dot head
i have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have all the different
columns except for the brand at the end
of the year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set you're going to get an
error later on and it'll say cannot
convert string to float value and that's
because if for some reason these things
the way they recorded them must been
recorded as strings so we have a neat
feature in here on pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert underscore
numeric numeric
equals
true and yes i did have to go look that
up i don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if i'm working with a
lot of these things i remember them but
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up and we run
that oops i must have missed something
in here let me double check my spelling
and when i double check my spelling
you'll see i missed the first underscore
in the convert objects when i run this
it now has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data and eliminate null
values
most people when they're doing small
amounts working with small data pools
discover afterwards that they have a
null value and they have to go back and
do this
so you know be aware whenever we're
formatting this data things are going to
pop up and sometimes you go backwards to
fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you have
and i should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in working with x dot
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take
x of i and we're going to change that
we're going to alter it
and so
with this we want to go ahead and fill
in
x of i pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data
then we'll put my brackets up and
there's a lot of different ways to fill
this data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
and then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data
one of the tricks we can do is we can
take our column and we can find the
means
and the means is in other or quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means the problem is that returns a
decimal float so some of these aren't
decimals
certainly let me be a little careful of
doing this but for this example we're
just going to fill it in with the
integer version of this it keeps it on
par with the other data that isn't a
decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right so we're
going to go through and test
for missing data
and one of the ways you can do that is
simply go in here
and take our x of i
column so it's going to go through the x
of i column it says is null
so it's going to return any any place
there's a null value it actually goes
through all the rows of each column is
null and then we want to go ahead and
sum that so we take that and we add the
sum value and these are all pandas so is
null is a panda command and so is sum
and if we go through that we go ahead
and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data
and at this point we're actually going
to
start using the elbow method to find the
optimal number of clusters so we're now
actually getting into the sk learn part
uh the k means clustering on here
i guess we'll go ahead and zoom it up
one more not so you can see what i'm
typing in here
and then from
sk learn we're going to our sk learn
cluster
i'm going to import
k
means
i always forget to capitalize the k and
the m when i do this so it's capital k
capital m k means
and we'll go and create a
ray w c s s equals let me get an empty
array if you remember from the elbow
method from our slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a square
distance and we're going to run this
over a number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
range 0 11
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create the actual
blue all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the k mean that we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this is in
clusters
we're going to set that equals to i
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings to the k-means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff is how you init your
k-means so we have k-means plus plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks its
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a max
iteration we put in there
we have the infinite the random state
equals zero you really don't need to
worry too much about these when you're
first learning this as you start digging
in deeper you start finding that these
are shortcuts that will speed up the
process
as far as the setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals i so we're going to literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times
and if you're working with big data you
know the first thing you do is you run a
small sample of the data so you can test
all your stuff on it and you can already
see the problem that if i'm going to
iterate through a terabyte of data 11
times and then the k means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times that's a heck of a process
so you got to be a little careful with
this a lot of times though you can find
your elbow using the elbow method find
your optimal number on a sample of data
especially if you're working with larger
data sources
so we want to go ahead and take our
k-means and we're just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the sklearn
very common that you fit your model and
if you remember correctly our variable
we're using is the capital x
and once we fit this value
we go back to the
array we made we want to go and just
depend that value on the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so k means dot inertia
will pull that specific value out that
we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our plt plot
and what we're plotting here
is first the x axis which is range 0
11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there
and the wcss for our y axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do plt
x
and what we'll do we'll do number of
clusters for that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph
which is simply plt dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline it'll appear in line
hopefully i didn't make a type error on
there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at uh two and again right around
three and four and then after that
there's not very much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output look like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use three as a setup on here
and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like when we actually use this
to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the cars data set
and basically we're going to copy the
code that we loop through up above where
k means equals k means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to three
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do three and four on
this and graph them just to see how they
come up differently be kind of curious
to look at that but for this we're just
going to set it to 3. go ahead and
create our own variable y
k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there to k means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see a slightly
different because usually you see fit
and then you see just the predict but we
want to both fit and predict the k-means
on this and let's fit underscore predict
and then our capital x is the data we're
working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set x as matrix
so we're converting this into a nice
rows and columns kind of set up but we
want the we're going to have columns
equals none so it's just going to be a
matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions
instead of matrix now that it's more
common to set it dot values instead of
doing as matrix but maths matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll want
to update that later on but let's go
ahead and dive in and plot this and see
what that looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data i always like to take a look and
see what i am plotting so let's take a
look at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 2. so it's clustering
these different
rows of data
based on the three different spaces it
thinks it's going to be
and then let's go ahead and print x and
see what we have for x and we'll see
that x is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first
two or positions zero and one
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting
you might actually do a little different
than and dig a little deeper into the
different aspects because this is all
the different columns we looked at but
we look at columns one and two for this
to make it easy so let's go ahead and
clear this data out of here and let's
bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so plt scatter
and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the x values
and we're only interested in y of k
means equals 0 the first cluster okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the x-axis and then we're going to do
the same thing here we're only
interested in
k means equals 0 but we're going to take
the second column so we're looking at
the first two columns in our answer or
in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
with as the size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data and
what came out it was definitely the
toyota on this we're just going to go
ahead and label it toyota again that's
something you really have to explore in
here
as far as playing with those numbers and
see what looks good we'll go ahead and
hit enter in there and i'm just going to
paste in the next
two lines which is the next two cars
and this is our nissa and honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where y underscore k
means equals one
and we want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and uh finally let's take a look and put
the centroids on there
again we're going to do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means the model we
created
dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with 0 and 1.
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them it's always good to have some good
labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title plt
title
and pop up there
plt title because you always want to
make your graphs look pretty and we'll
call it clusters of car make
and one of the features of the
plot library is you can add
legend it'll automatically bring in
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's inline so if you're using a
different editor that's not the jupiter
notebook you'll get a pop-up of this
and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this we
have a clusters of honda and green
toyota and red
nissan and purple and you can see where
they put the centroids to separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other different data
on here as far because we only looked at
the first two columns this is just
column one and two or zero one as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have a nice clusters of
car make and we were able to pull out
the data and you can see how just these
two columns
form very distinct clusters of data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the data and pulling apart
the columns to find out
why is the first group set up the way it
is maybe you're doing loans and you want
to go well why is this group not
defaulting on their loans and why is the
last group defaulting on their loans and
why is the middle group 50 defaulting on
their bank loans and you start finding
ways to manipulate the data and pull out
the answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use
k-mean for clustering
let's move on to the next topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm is the
simplest classification algorithm used
for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from canada who's into
horror books is back that's actually
really scary when you think about that
with those big eyes in the previous
tutorial we learned about linear
regression dependent and independent
variables so to brush up y equals mx
plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1 all the way
up to xn are the features or attributes
we are going to use to predict the
target class
we know what a linear regression looks
like but using the graph we cannot
divide the outcome into categories
it's really hard to categorize 1.5 3.6
9.8
for example a linear regression graph
can tell us that with increase in number
of hours studied the marks of a student
will increase but it will not tell us
whether the student will pass or not in
such cases where we need the output as
categorical value we will use logistic
regression and for that we're going to
use the sigmoid function so you can see
here we have our marks 0 to 100 number
of hours studied that's going to be what
they're comparing it to in this example
and we usually form a line that says y
equals mx plus c and when we use the
sigmoid function we have p equals 1 over
1 plus e to the minus y
it generates a sigmoid curve and so you
can see right here when you take the ln
which is the natural logarithm i always
thought it should be nl not ln that's
just the inverse of
e your e to the minus y and so we do
this we get ln of p over one minus p
equals m times x plus c that's the
sigmoid curve function we're looking for
and we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to 1 or to 0 depending on
what your x value is and the probability
if it's greater than 0.5 the value is
automatically rounded off to one
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass then
you have a threshold value at the point
five it automatically puts that right in
the middle usually and your probability
if it's less than 0.5 the value rendered
off to zero indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outliers or
that one student is just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately i have to study hard to
learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant or benign and this is
actually one of my favorite data sets to
play with because it has so many
features and when you look at them you
really are hard to understand you can't
just look at them and know the answer so
it gives you a chance to kind of dive
into what data looks like when you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but i also want you
to remind you that in the domain of
medicine if i told you that my
probability
was really good it classified things
that say 90 or 95 and i'm classifying
whether you're going to have a malignant
or a b9 tumor i'm guessing that you're
going to go get it tested anyways so you
got to remember the domain we're working
with so why would you want to do that if
you know you're just going to go get a
biopsy because you know it's that
serious this is like an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor know
where to look just by understanding what
kind of tumor it is so it might help
them or aid them and something they
missed from before so let's go ahead and
dive into the code and i'll come back to
the domain part of it in just a minute
so use case and we're going to do our
normal imports here we're importing
numpy pandas seaborn the matplot library
and we're going to do matplot library in
line since i'm going to switch over to
anaconda so let's go ahead and flip over
there and get this started
so i've opened up a new window in my
anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupyter notebook i just love the
interface and all the tools and anaconda
brings so we got our import numpy as in
p
for our numpy number array we have our
pandas pd we're going to bring in
seaborn to help us with our graphs as
sns
so many really nice tools in both
seaborne and matplot library and we'll
do our
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt and then of
course we want to let it know to do it
in line and let's go and just run that
so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data
not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file
so we'll use a pd.read underscore csv
and i happen to name the file i renamed
it data for
p2.csv you can of course write in the
comments below the youtube and request
for the data set itself or go to the
simply learn website and we'll be happy
to supply that for you
and let's just open up the data before
we go any further and let's just see
what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a csv file
comma separated variables we have an id
so i guess the
categorizes for reference or what id
which test was done the diagnosis
m for malignant b for b9 so there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're going to try to predict is
the m and b and test it and then we have
like the radius
mean or average the texture average
perimeter mean area mean smoothness i
don't know about you but unless you're a
doctor in the field most of stuff i mean
you can guess what concave means just by
the term concave but i really wouldn't
know what that means in the measurements
they're taking so they have all kinds of
stuff like how smooth it is
the symmetry and these are all float
values let me just page through them
real quick and you'll see there's i
believe 36 if i remember correctly in
this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth
so back in our data and i put this in
the same folder as a code so i saved
this code in that folder obviously if
you have it in a different location you
want to put the full path in there and
we'll just do
pandas
first five lines of data with the data
dot head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely
for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn which we referenced as sns
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot you'll notice that
very similar to because it is sitting on
top of the plot library so the joint
plot does a lot of work for us and we're
just going to look at the first two
columns that we're interested in the
radius mean and the texture mean we'll
just look at those two columns
and data
equals data so that tells it which two
columns we're plotting and that we're
going to use the data that we pulled in
let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at i mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram they show
that for the radius mean whereas the
most commonest radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is so
we're looking at the tech the on each
growth its average texture and on each
radius its average uh radius on there it
gets a little confusing because we're
talking about the individual objects
average and then we can also look over
here and see the the histogram showing
us the median or how common each
measurement is
and that's only two columns so let's dig
a little deeper into seaborn they also
have a heat map and if you're not
familiar with heat maps a heat map just
means it's in color that's all that
means heat map i guess the original ones
were plotting heat density on something
and so ever since then it's just called
a heat map and we're going to take our
data and get our corresponding numbers
to put that into the heat map and that's
simply data dot c-o-r-r
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas for our data and this is
pull that information into a heat map
and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
id we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points
and if you look down the middle of this
chart diagonal going from the upper left
to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're a hundred percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture so these have almost no
corresponding data they don't really
form a linear graph or something that
you can look at and say how connected
they are they're very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data doesn't
so much change what you do but it
changes verifying so when you get an
answer or something like that or you
start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here and we can see from
the id
there's no real one feature that just
says if you go across the top line that
lights up there's no one feature that
says hey if the area is a certain size
then it's going to be b9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to id this whether it's
malignant or b9 that's a big hint to us
as data scientists to go okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data let's explore one
more area and let's look at data dot is
null we want to check for
null values in our data if you remember
from earlier in this tutorial we did it
a little differently where we added
stuff up and sum them up you can
actually with pandas do it really
quickly data dot is null and summit and
it's going to go across all the columns
so when i run this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no no data
so we've just just to re hash these last
few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seen how they plot with the seaborn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram
and the data plotted on the x y
coordinates and obviously you can do
that more in detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the seaborn
heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms a
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values okay
so not a big deal if you miss it but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you've got to go
remember where you were pulling the data
in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x
and our y
let me just put that down here and we'll
set the x equal to and there's a lot of
different options here certainly we
could do x equals all the columns except
for the first two because if you
remember the first two is the id and the
diagnosis so that certainly would be an
option
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on the worst the worst
radius the worst texture parameter area
smoothness compactness
and so on one of the reasons to start
dividing your data up when you're
looking at this information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming in to my model it might overweigh
them it might overpower the other
measurements because it's measuring it's
basically taking that information in
twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial i want you to take away
from this though is that we are dividing
the data up into pieces and our team in
the back went ahead and said hey let's
just look at the worst so i'm going to
create a an array
and you'll see this array
radius worst texture worse perimeter
worst we've just taken the worst of the
worst and i'm just going to put that in
my x so this x is still a pandas data
frame but it's just those columns and
our y if you remember correctly
is going to be oops hold on one second
it's not x it's data there we go so x
equals data and then it's a list of the
different columns the worst of the worst
and if we're going to take that then we
have to have our answer for our y for
the stuff we know
and if you remember correctly we're just
going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it b9 or
malignant
and since it's a single column we can
just do diagnosis oh i forgot to put the
brackets or there we go okay so it's
just diagnosis on there and we can also
real quickly do like x dot head if you
want to see what that looks like
and y dot head
and run this
and you'll see
it only does the last one i forgot about
that if you don't do print you can see
that the the y dot head is just mmm
because the first ones are all malignant
and if i run this the x dot head is just
the first five values of radius worst
texture worse parameter worst areaworks
and so on
i'll go ahead and take that out
so moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your
model
so we do that by splitting the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import train test split so
we're going to split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is past the scope of this and for
this particular example isn't necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the
sklearn dot model selection we have
train test split you can write your own
quick code to do this we just randomly
divide the data up into two groups but
they do it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables
capital x train capital x test so we
have our training data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported
and we're going to do x and our y our
two different data that's going in for
our split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size equals 0.3 that's test underscore
size random state it's always nice to
kind of switch the random state around
but not that important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30 percent of the
data and we're going to put that into
our test variables our y test and our x
test and we're going to do 70 into the x
train and the y train so we're going to
use 70 of the data to train our model
and 30 to test it
let's go ahead and run that and load
those up
so now we have all our stuff split up
and all our data ready to go
now we get to the actual logistics part
we're actually going to do our create
our model so let's go ahead and bring
that in from sklearn we're going to
bring in our linear model and we're
going to import logistic regression
that's the actual model we're using and
this we'll call it log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to our logistic regression that we
just imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the
models in the sk learn we just need to
go ahead and fix it fit do a fit on
there and we use our x train that we
separated out with our y
train and let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data that 70 of our
training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make but
for word though we're just going to let
all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example and there's nothing
in here that really stands out as super
important until you start fine-tuning it
but for what we're doing the basics will
work just fine and then let's we need to
go ahead and test out our model is it
working so let's create a variable y
predict
and this is going to be equal to
our log model
and we want to do a predict again very
standard format for the sk learn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it and we're going to test why
predict against the y test so we want to
know what the model thinks it's going to
be that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x
test so we have our train set and our
test set and now we're going to do our y
predict and let's go ahead and run that
and if we print
y
predict
let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of uh b and m
for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there so that's pretty good we're not
sure exactly how good it does but we can
see that it actually works and it's
functional was very easy to create
you'll always discover with our data
science that as you explore this
you spend a significant amount of time
prepping your data
and making sure your data coming in is
good
there's a saying
good data in good answers out bad data
in
bad answers out that's only half the
thing that's only half of it selecting
your models becomes the next part as far
as how good your models are and then of
course fine tuning it depending on what
model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predictor log model dot predict x test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
classification report
and that just reports how good our model
is doing and then we're going to feed it
the model data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual
data so this is what we actually know is
true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
we pull that up you'll see that we have
a precision for b9 and malignant b and m
and we have a precision of 93 at 91 a
total of 92 so it's kind of the average
between these two 92
there's all kinds of different
information on here your f1 score
your recall your support coming through
on this
and for this i'll go ahead and just flip
back to our slides that they put
together for describing it and so here
we're going to look at the precision
using the classification report and you
see this is the same printout i had up
above some of the numbers might be
different because it does randomly pick
out which data we're using so this model
is able to predict the type of tumor
with 91
accuracy so we look back here let's you
will see where we have b9 in england it
actually has 92 coming up here but we're
looking at about a 92 91 precision and
remember i reminded you about domains
and we're talking about the domain of a
medical domain with a very catastrophic
outcome you know at 91 or 92 percent
precision you're still going to go in
there and have somebody do a biopsy on
it very different than if you're
investing money and there's a 92 percent
chance you're going to earn 10 percent
and 8 chance you're going to lose 8
you're probably going to bet the money
because at that odds it's pretty good
that you'll make some money and in the
long run you do that enough you
definitely will make money and also with
this domain i've actually seen them use
this to identify different forms of
cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate
so that wraps up this section today
we're going to be looking at random
forest one of the many powerful tools in
the machine learning library before we
dive into the topic let's start by
looking at a few of the uses for random
forest currently today it's used in
remote sensing uh for example they're
used in the etm devices if you're a
space buff that's the enhanced thermatic
mapper they use on satellites which see
uh far outside the human spectrum for
looking at land masses and they acquire
images of the earth's surface the
accuracy is higher and training time is
less than many other machine learning
tools out there also object detection
multi-class object detection is done
using random forest algorithms a good
example is a traffic where you're trying
to sort out the different cars buses and
things and it provides a better
detection in complicated environments
they're very complicated up there and
then we have
another example connect and let's take a
little closer look at connect connect
they use a random forest as part of the
game console
and what it does is it tracks the body
movements and it recreates it in the
game and let's see what that looks like
we have a user who performs a step in
this case it looks like elvis presley
going there
that is then recorded so the connect
registers the movement
and then it marks the user based on
accuracy and it looks like we have
prints going on this one
from
elvis press leader prince that's great
uh so mark's user based on the accuracy
if we look at that a little closer we
have a training set to identify body
parts where are the hands where the feet
what's going on with the body
that then goes into a random forest
classifier that learns from it
once we've trained the classifier
and then identifies the body parts while
the person's dancing it's able to
represent that in a computer format and
then based on that it scores the game
and how accurate you are as being elvis
presley or prince in your dancing so why
random forest it's always important to
understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with
the random forest the first one is
there's no overfitting if you use of
multiple trees reduce the risk of
overfitting training time is less
overfitting means that we have fit the
data so close to what we have as our
sample that we pick up on all the weird
parts and instead of predicting the
overall data you're predicting the weird
stuff which you don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area and
they took a slightly different set of
statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest random forest or random decision
forest is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as the final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switch from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well it goes hmm
orange or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes those decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
then they also have information gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set 1 and a data set 2 we just
split it in two and if you look at these
new
data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision so we look down here to the
leaf node we finally get to our set one
or our set two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one
it's going to be split by some means and
we'll either end up with apples on the
leaf node or a lemon on the leaf node
and on the right it'll either be an
apple or lemons those leaf nodes are
those final decisions or classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the
five apples and one lemon and in the
other case the five lemons in one apple
they have to make a choice of which tree
it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty high
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much
less chaos going on there this note has
already attained an entropy value of 0
as you can see there's only one kind of
label left for this branch so no further
splitting is required for this node
however this node on the right is still
requires a split to decrease the entropy
further so we split the right node
further based on color if you look at
this if i split it on color that pretty
much cuts it right down the middle it's
the only thing we have left in our
choices of color and diameter too and if
the color is yellow it's going to go to
the right bowl and if it's false it's
going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there so we've looked at kind of a basic
tree
in our forest but what we really want to
know is how does a random forest work as
a whole so to begin our
random forest classifier let's say we
already have built three trees and we're
going to start with the first tree that
looks like this
just like we did in the example this
tree looks at the diameter if it's
greater than or equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger diameter and if the
color is orange it's going to go to the
right true we're using oranges now
instead of lemons and if it's red it's
going to go to the left false we build a
second tree very similar but split
differently instead of the first one
being split by a diameter this one when
they created it if you look at that
first bowl it has a lot of red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right and then it looks
at the shape false are true and so on
and so on and tree three is the diameter
equal to one and it came up with this
because there's a lot of cherries in
this bowl so that would be the biggest
split on there is is the diameter equal
to one that's going to drop the entropy
the quickest and as you can see it
splits it into true if it goes false and
they've added another category does it
grow in the summer and if it's false
it goes off to the left if it's true it
goes off to the right let's go ahead and
bring these three trees so you can see
them all in one image so this would be
three completely different trees
categorizing a fruit and let's take a
fruit now let's try this and this fruit
if you look at it we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked about earlier is that a random
forest works really good if you're
missing data if you're missing pieces so
this fruit has an image but maybe the
person had a black and white camera when
they took the picture and we're going to
take a look at this and it's going to
have they put the color in there so
ignore the color down there but the
diameter equals 3 we find out it grows
in the summer equals yes and the shape
is a circle and if you go to the right
you can look at what one of the decision
trees did this is the third one
is a diameter greater than equal to
three is the color orange well it
doesn't really know on this one but if
you look at the value and say true and
go to the right tree two classifies it
as cherries is the color equal red
is the shape a circle true it is a
circle so this would look at it and say
oh that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one well that's false
does it grow in the summer true so it
goes down and looks at as oranges so how
does this random forest work the first
one says it's an orange
the second one said it was a cherry and
the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry uh
when you add that all together the
majority of the vote says orange so the
answer is it's classified as an orange
even though we didn't know the color and
we're missing data on it i don't know
about you but i'm getting tired of fruit
so let's switch and i did promise you
we'd start looking at a case example and
get into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
this is the exciting part as we roll up
our sleeves and actually look at some
python coding before we start the python
coding we need to go ahead and create a
problem statement wonder what species of
iris do these flowers belong to let's
try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in python
let's see how it can be done so here we
begin to go ahead and implement our
python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and i've already opened up a
new page for python 3 code and i'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.dataset
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module that
allows us to bring in the data the load
iris and the iris is so popular it's
been around since 1936 when ronald
fisher published a paper on it and
they're measuring the different parts of
the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import a random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn.ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules
and these are probably the most commonly
used modules in python and data science
with any of the
other modules that we bring in and one
is going to be pandas we're going to
import pandas as pd pd is a common term
used for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us
where when you create a pandas data
frame it looks like an excel spreadsheet
and you'll see that in a minute when we
start digging deeper into the code panda
is just wonderful because it plays nice
with all the other modules in there and
then we have numpy which is our numbers
python and the numbers python allows us
to do different mathematical sets on
here we'll see right off the bat we're
going to take our np and we're going to
go ahead and seed the randomness with it
with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is zero
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupiter notebook and here we go we've
gone ahead and run the imports
and i'm going to paste the code down
here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the df to
define data frame
and that's going to equal pd and if
remember that's pandas as pd so that's
our pandas
and panda data frame and then we're
looking at iris data
and columns equals iris feature names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created what looks like
an excel spreadsheet
and in this excel spreadsheet we have
set the columns so up on the top you can
see the four different columns and then
we have the data iris.data down below
it's a little confusing without knowing
where this data is coming from so let's
look at the bigger picture and i'm going
to go print i'm just going to change
this for a moment and we're going to
print all of iris and see what that
looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary and in a
python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label and this
label pulls up whatever information
comes after it so feature names which we
actually used over here under columns is
equal to an array of sepal length sepal
width petal length petal width these are
the different names they have for the
four different columns and if you scroll
down far enough you'll also see data
down here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head it'll print the
first five lines of the data set in
there along with the headers if you have
it in this case we have the column
header set to iris features and in here
you'll see that we have zero one two
three four in python most arrays always
start at zero so when you look at the
first five it's going to be zero one two
three four not one two three four five
so now we've got our iris data imported
into a data frame let's take a look at
the next piece of code in here and so in
this section here
of the code
we're going to take a look at the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupyter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here and
before i run it
i want to look at a couple things going
on so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column and here we have
iris.target
now these are both in the pandas setup
on here so in pandas we can do either
one i could have just as easily done
iris and then in brackets target
depending on what i'm working on both
are acceptable
let's go ahead and run this code and see
how this changes and what we've done is
we've added the target from the iris
data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our neural network to
look for these this different data and
know what a setosa is or a vera color
which we'll see in just a minute or
virginica those are the three that are
in there and now we're going to add one
more column i know we're organizing all
this data over and over again it's kind
of fun there's a lot of ways to organize
it what's nice about putting everything
onto one
data frame is i can then do a printout
and it shows me exactly what i'm looking
at and i'll show you that where you
where that's different where you can
alter that and do it slightly
differently but let's go ahead and put
this into our script up to that now and
here we go we're going to put that down
here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data
and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it df remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals np remember
that stands for numpy.random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1. and we're going to do
it for each of the rows that's where the
length df comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 percent of the data roughly because
there's a randomness involved and we're
going to use that to train it and then
the other 25 we're going to hold off to
the side and use that to test it later
on so let's flip back on over and see
what the next step is so now that we've
labeled our database for which is
training and which is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables train and test and
let's take this code and let's bring it
into our project and here we go let's
paste it on down here and before i run
this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train
one's called test 75 and train 25
percent in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is train equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and that's make it readable to
humans
i don't know about you but i hate
looking at zeros and ones
so let's start with the features and
let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the df columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width pedal
length and pedal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing i want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook or you're
running command line in the terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when i run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about jupyter notebooks
is i'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that for our
final step in prepping our data before
we actually start running the training
and the testing is we're going to go
ahead and convert the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to pd dot factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas right here pd
factorize what's factorized doing i'm
going to come back to that in just a
second
let's look at what train species is
and why we're looking at the group 0 on
there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on that we created this
whole column here for species
and then it has setosa setosa setosa
setosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and veracolor
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the train species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact that there's only three of them so
when i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go
uh we have
two lines of code oh my goodness that
was a lot of work to get to two lines of
code but there is a lot in these two
lines of code so let's take a look and
see what's going on here and put this
into our full script that we're running
and let's paste this in here and let's
take a look and see what this is we have
we're creating a variable clf and we're
going to set this equal to the random
forest classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard
in jobs all that does is to prioritize
it not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts
zero is fine for here
but uh let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf
dot fit so we're fitting we're training
it we are actually creating our random
forest classifier right here this is the
code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set remember
we kept our test off to the side and
we're going to take our training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target the y
so the y is 0 1 and 2 that we just
created and the features is the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set
let's go ahead and run that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and i typed in
y and printed out y instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two
you can see the random state equals zero
those are the two that we sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these different meanings of
all these different settings on here
some of them are self-explanatory if you
kind of think about it a little bit like
max features as auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we had the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this we're looking at a
lot of stuff here so you might have in
this case there's probably only think
three leaf nodes maybe four you might
have thousands of leaf nodes at which
point you do need to put a cap on that
and say okay can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is limiting the process and
making sure we don't overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them warm start equals false form start
is if you're programming it one piece at
a time externally since we're not we're
not going to have like we're not going
to continually train this particular
learning tree and again like i said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the sk learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit our train our features and our
target y so now we have our training
model
what's next if we're going to create a
model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the versacolor and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here so you can
see what features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames you'll see that it's
an index so when you put an index in
like this
into
test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2 and we're going to
put those in and we're going to predict
what our
new
forest classifier is going to come up
with and this is what it predicts it
predicts zero zero zero one two one one
two two two and and uh again this is the
flower type setosa virginica and
versacolor so now that we've taken our
test features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us so the first
thing we can do with our predicts is we
can actually generate a different
prediction model when i say different
we're going to view it differently it's
not that the data itself is different so
let's take this next piece of code and
put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf.predict
probability so we're running it just
like we ran it up here but this time
with this we're going to get a slightly
different result and we're only going to
look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them
which was uh what 27 you'll see right
down here that this generates a much
larger field on the probability and
let's take a look and see what that
looks like
and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting a one for setosa it predicts
a zero for virginica and it predicts a
zero for versa color and so on and so on
and so on and let's um you know what i'm
going to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5
and so if we're going vote and we have
two equal votes it's gonna go with the
first one so it says uh setosa gets zero
votes virginica gets point five votes
versus color gets point five votes but
let's just go with the virginica since
these two are equal and so on and so on
down the list you can see how they vary
on here so now we've looked at both how
to do a basic predict of the features
and we've looked at the predict
probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and this we're going to do in these
next two steps we're going to start by
setting up our predictions and mapping
them to the name so let's see what that
looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to it a little bit so here's iris
dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the the names that we've been
talking about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run it we could have just
set a variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that returns the
zeros the ones and the twos and then
we're going to set that equal to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable and when i run
this
it distributes it it comes out as an
array and the array is setosa satosa
satosa satosa setosa we're only looking
at the first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there and you'll
see that it starts mapping it to all the
different flower types the versa color
and the virginica in there and let's see
how this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it
and let's talk about both these sections
of code here
and how they go together
the first one is our predictions and i
went ahead and did predictions through
25 let's just do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species i remember i could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says setosa satoshi satosa
setosa and they match
so the first one is what our
forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna because i'm on the
jupiter notebook i can do a control
minus so you can see the whole line
there
there we go resize it
and let's take a look and see what's
going on here we're gonna create in
pandas remember pd stands for pandas and
we're doing a cross tab this function
takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versa color virginica and the actual
species setosa versacolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versus color where they meet and you
have virginica where they meet and
they're meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30. if you add 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get
30. and then we notice here where it
says virginica but it was supposed to be
versacolor this is inaccurate so now we
have two two inaccurate predictions and
30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy is 93 that's
just 30 divided by 32 and if we multiply
it by a hundred we can say that it is 93
percent accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting before we wrap it up so let's
flip back on over to my script in here
we're going to take this line of code
from up above i don't know if you
remember it but predix equals the iris
dot target underscore names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point i
would go ahead and change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create data maybe let's
just do two flowers so maybe i'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then i actually want to see what the
answer are is so let's go ahead and type
in preds and print that out and when i
run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since i put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual
end product going out to be used on data
that you don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this introducing naive
bayes classifier have you ever wondered
how your mail provider implements spam
filtering or how online news channels
perform news text classification or how
companies perform sentimental analysis
of their audience on social media all of
this and more is done through a machine
learning algorithm called naive bayes
classifier welcome to naive bayes
tutorial my name is richard kirschner
i'm with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead what's in it for you we'll start
with what is naive bayes a basic
overview of how it works we'll get into
naive bayes and machine learning where
it fits in with our other machine
learning tools why do we need naive
bayes and understanding naive bayes
classifier a much more in depth of how
the math works in the background finally
we'll get into the advantages of the
nave bayes classifier in the machine
learning setup and then we'll roll up
our sleeves and do my favorite part
we'll actually do some python coding and
do some text classification using the
naive bayes what is naive bayes let's
start with a basic introduction to the
bayes theorem named after thomas bayes
from the 1700s who first coined this in
the western literature naive bayes
classifier works on the principle of
conditional probability as given by the
bayes theorem before we move ahead let
us go through some of the simple
concepts in the probability that we will
be using let us consider the following
example of tossing two coins here we
have two quarters and if we look at all
the different possibilities of what they
can come up as we get that they could
come up as head heads come up as head
tail tail head and tell tale when doing
the math on probability we usually
denote probability as a p a capital p so
the probability of getting two heads
equals one fourth you can see on our
data set we have two heads and this
occurs once out of the four
possibilities and then the probability
of at least one tail occurs three
quarters of the time you'll see in three
of the coin tosses we have tails in them
and out of four that's three-fourths and
then the probability of the second coin
being head given the first coin is tail
is one half and the probability of
getting two heads given the first coin
is a head is one half we'll demonstrate
that in just a minute and show you how
that math works now when we're doing it
with two coins it's easy to see but when
you have something more complex you can
see where these pro these formulas
really come in and work so the bayes
theorem gives us the conditional
probability of an event a given another
event b has occurred in this case the
first coin toss will be b and the second
coin toss a this can be confusing
because we've actually reversed the
order of them and go from b to a instead
of a to b you'll see this a lot when you
work in probabilities the reason is
we're looking for event a we want to
know what that is so we're going to
label that a since that's our focus and
then given another event b has occurred
in the bayes theorem as you can see on
the left the probability of a occurring
given b has occurred
equals the probability of b occurring
given a has occurred times a probability
of a over the probability of b this
simple formula can be moved around just
like any algebra formula and we could do
the probability of a after a given b
times probability of b equals the
probability of b given a times
probability of a you can easily move
that around and multiply it and divide
it out let us apply bayes theorem to our
example here we have our two quarters
and we'll notice that the first two
probabilities of getting two heads and
at least one tail we compute directly
off the data so you can easily see that
we have
one example h out of four one fourth and
we have three with tails in them giving
us three quarters or three four seventy
five percent
the second condition the second uh set
three and four we're gonna explore a
little bit more in detail now we stick
to a simple example with two coins
because you can easily understand the
math the probability of throwing a tail
doesn't matter what comes before it and
the same with the head so still going to
be 50 percent or one half but when that
come when that probability gets more
complicated let's say you have a d6 dice
or some other instance then this formula
really comes in handy but let's stick to
the simple example for now in this
sample space let a be the event that the
second coin is head and b be the event
that the first coin is tells again we
reversed it because we want to know what
the second event is going to be so we're
going to be focusing on a and we write
that out as a probability of a given b
and we know this from our formula that
that equals the probability of b given a
times the probability of a over the
probability of b and when we plug that
in we plug in the probability of the
first coin being tells given the second
coin is heads and the probability of the
second coin being heads given the first
coin being over the probability of the
first coin being tails when we plug that
data in and we have the probability of
the first coin being tails given the
second coin is heads times the
probability of the second coin being
heads over the probability of the first
coin being tails you can see it's a
simple formula to calculate we have one
half times one half over one half or one
half equals point five or 4. so the
bayes theorem basically calculates the
conditional probability of the
occurrence of an event based on prior
knowledge of conditions that might be
related to the event we will explore
this in detail when we take up an
example of online shopping further in
this tutorial understanding naive bayes
and machine learning like with any of
our other machine learning tools it's
important to understand where the naive
bayes fits in the hierarchy so under the
machine learning we have supervised
learning and there is other things like
unsupervised learning there's also
reward system this falls under the
supervised learning and then under the
supervised learning there's
classification there's also regression
but we're going to be in the
classification side and then under
classification is your naive bayes let's
go ahead and glance into where is naive
bayes used let's look at some of the use
scenarios for it as a classifier we use
it in face recognition is this cindy or
is it not cindy or whoever or it might
be used to identify parts of the face
that they then feed into another part of
the face recognition program this is the
eye this is the nose this is the mouth
weather prediction is it going to be
rainy or sunny medical recognition news
prediction it's also used in medical
diagnosis we might diagnose somebody as
either as high risk or not as high risk
for cancer or heart disease or other
ailments and news classification when
you look at the google news and it says
well is this political or is this world
news or a lot of that's all done with
the naive bayes understanding naive
bayes classifier now we already went
through a basic understanding with the
coins and the two heads and two tails
and head tail tail heads etc we're going
to do just a quick review on that and
remind you that the naive bayes
classifier is based on the bayes theorem
which gives a conditional probability of
event a given event b and that's where
the probability of a given b equals the
probability of b given a times
probability of a over probability of b
remember this is an algebraic function
so we can move these different entities
around we can multiply by the
probability of b so it goes to the left
hand side and then we can divide by the
probability of a given b and just as
easily come up with a new formula for
the probability of b to me staring at
these algebraic functions kind of gives
me a slight headache
it's a lot better to see if we can
actually understand how this data fits
together in a table and let's go ahead
and start applying it to some actual
data so you can see what that looks like
so we're going to start with the
shopping demo problem statement and
remember we're going to solve this first
in table form so you can see what the
math looks like and then we're going to
solve it in python and in here we want
to predict whether the person will
purchase a product are they going to buy
or don't buy very important if you're
running a business you want to know how
to maximize your profits or at least
maximize the purchase of the people
coming into your store and we're going
to look at a specific combination of
different variables in this case we're
going to look at the day the discount
and the free delivery and you can see
here under the day we want to know
whether it's on the weekday you know
somebody's working they come in after
work or maybe they don't work weekend
you can see the bright colors coming
down there celebrating not being in work
or holiday and did we offer a discount
that day yes or no did we offer free
delivery that day yes or no and from
this we want to know whether the person
is going to buy based on these traits so
we can maximize them and find out the
best system for getting somebody to come
in and purchase our goods and products
from our store now having a nice visual
is great but we do need to dig into the
data so let's go ahead and take a look
at the data set
we have a small sample data set of 30
rows we're showing you the first 15 of
those roads for this demo now the actual
data file you can request just type in
below under the comments on the youtube
video and we'll send you some more
information and send you that file as
you can see here the file is very simple
columns and rows we have the day the
discount the free delivery and did the
person purchase or not and then we have
under the day whether it was a weekday a
holiday was at the weekend this is a
pretty simple set of data and long
before computers people used to look at
this data and calculate this all by hand
so let's go ahead and walk through this
and see what that looks like when we put
that into tables also note in today's
world we're not usually looking at three
different variables in 30 rows nowadays
because we're able to collect data so
much we're usually looking at 27 30
variables across hundreds of rows the
first thing we want to do is we're going
to take this data and based on the data
set containing our three inputs day
discount and free delivery we're going
to go ahead and populate that to
frequency tables for each attribute so
we want to know if they had a discount
how many people
buy and did not buy did they have a
discount yes or no do we have a free
delivery yes or no on those dates how
many people made a purchase how many
people didn't and the same with the
three days of the week was it a weekday
a weekend a holiday and did they buy yes
or no as we dig in deeper to this table
for our bayes theorem let the event by
be a now remember we looked at the coins
i said we really want to know what the
outcome is did the person buy or not and
that's usually event a is what you're
looking for and the independent
variables discount free delivery and day
bb so we'll call that probability of b
now let us calculate the likelihood
table for one of the variables let's
start with day which includes weekday
weekend and holiday and let us start by
summing all of our rows so we have the
weekday row and out of the weekdays
there's nine plus two so it's 11
weekdays there's eight weekend days and
11 holidays well it's a lot of holidays
and then we want to sum up the total
number of days so we're looking at a
total of 30 days let's start pulling
some information from our chart and see
where that takes us and when we fill in
the chart on the right you can see that
9 out of 24 purchases are made on the
weekday 7 out of 24 purchases on the
weekend and 8 out of 24 purchases on a
holiday and out of all the people who
come in 24 out of 30 purchase you can
also see how many people do not purchase
on the weekdays two out of six didn't
purchase and so on and so on we can also
look at the totals and you'll see on the
right we put together some of the
formulas the probability of making a
purchase on the weekend comes out 11 out
of 30. so out of the 30 people who came
into the store throughout the weekend
weekday and holiday 11 of those
purchases were made on the weekday and
then you can also see the probability of
them not making a purchase and this is
done for doesn't matter which day of the
week so we call that probability of no
buy would be 6 over 30 or 0.2 so there's
a 20 chance that they're not going to
make a purchase no matter what day of
the week it is and finally we look at
the probability of bfa in this case
we're going to look at the probability
of the weekday and not buying two of the
no buys were done out of the weekend out
of the six people who did not make
purchases so when we look at that
probability of the weekday without a
purchase is going to be 0.33 or 33
percent let's take a look at this at
different probabilities and based on
this likelihood table let's go ahead and
calculate conditional probabilities as
below the first three we just did the
probability of making a purchase on the
weekday is 11 out of 30 or roughly 36 or
37 percent 0.367 the probability of not
making a purchase at all doesn't matter
what day of the week is roughly 0.2 or
20 percent and the probability of a
weekday no purchase is roughly two out
of six so two out of six of our no
purchases were made on the weekday and
then finally we take our p of a b
if you look we've kept the symbols up
there we got p of probability of b
probability of a probability of b if a
we should remember that the probability
of a if b is equal to the first one
times the probability of no buys over
the probability of the weekday so we
could calculate it both off the table we
created we can also calculate this by
the formula and we get the 0.367 which
equals or 0.33 times 0.2 over 0.367
which equals 0.179
or roughly 17 to 18 percent and that'd
be the probability of no purchase done
on the weekday and this is important
because we can look at this and say as
the probability of buying on the weekday
is more than the probability of not
buying on the weekday we can conclude
that customers will most likely buy the
product on a weekday now we've kept our
charts simple and we're only looking at
one aspect so you should be able to look
at the table and come up with the same
information or the same conclusion that
should be kind of intuitive at this
point next we can take the same setup we
have the frequency tables of all three
independent variables now we can
construct the likelihood tables for all
three of the variables we're working
with we can take our day like we did
before we have weekday weekend and
holiday we filled in this table and then
we can come in and also do that for the
discount yes or no did they buy yes or
no and we fill in that full table so now
we have our probabilities for a discount
and whether the discount leads to a
purchase or not and the probability for
free delivery does that lead to a
purchase or not and this is where it
starts getting really exciting let us
use these three likelihood tables to
calculate whether a customer will
purchase a product on a specific
combination of day discount and free
delivery or not purchase here let us
take a combination of these factors day
equals holiday discount equals yes free
delivery equals yes let's dig deeper
into the math and actually see what this
looks like and we're going to start with
looking for the probability of them not
purchasing on the following combinations
of days we're actually looking for the
probability of a equal no buy no
purchase and our probability of b we're
going to set equal to is it a holiday
did they get a discount yes and was it a
free delivery yes before we go further
let's look at the original equation the
probability of a if b equals the
probability of b given the condition a
and the probability times probability of
a over the probability of b occurring
now this is basic algebra so we can
multiply this information together so
when you see the probability of a given
b in this case the condition is b c and
d or the three different variables we're
looking at and when you see the
probability of b that would be the
conditions we're actually going to
multiply those three separate conditions
out probability of you'll see that in a
second in the formula times the full
probability of a over the full
probability of b so here we are back to
this and we're going to have let a equal
no purchase and we're looking for the
probability of b on the condition a
where a sets for three different things
remember that equals the probability of
a given the condition b
and in this case we just multiply those
three different variables together so we
have the probability of the discount
times the probability of free delivery
times the probability is a day equal a
holiday those are our three variables of
the probability of a if b and then that
is going to be multiplied by the
probability of them not making a
purchase and then we want to divide that
by the total probabilities and they're
multiplied together so we have the
probability of a discount the
probability of a free delivery and the
probability of it being on a holiday
when we plug those numbers in we see
that one out of six were no purchase on
a discounted day two out of six were a
no purchase on a free delivery day and
three out of six were a no purchase on a
holiday those are our three
probabilities of a of b multiplied out
and then that has to be multiplied by
the probability of a no purchase and
remember the prop probability of a no
buy is across all the data so that's
where we get the 6 out of 30. we divide
that out by the probability of each
category over the total number so we get
the 20 out of 30 had a discount 23 out
of 30 had a yes for free delivery and 11
out of 30 were on a holiday we plug all
those numbers in we get
0.178 so in our probability math we have
a 0.178 if it's a no buy for a holiday a
discount and a free delivery let's turn
that around and see what that looks like
if we have a purchase i promise this is
the last page of math before we dig into
the python script so here we're
calculating the probability of the
purchase using the same math we did to
find out if they didn't buy now we want
to know if they did buy and again we're
going to go by the day equals a holiday
discount equals yes free delivery equals
yes and let a equal buy now right about
now you might be asking why are we doing
both calculations why why would we want
to know the no buys and buys for the
same data going in well we're going to
show you that in just a moment but we
have to have both of those pieces of
information so that we can figure it out
as a percentage as opposed to a
probability equation and we'll get to
that normalization here in just a moment
let's go ahead and walk through this
calculation and as you can see here the
probability of a on the condition of b b
being all three categories did we have a
discount with a purchase do we have a
free delivery with a purchase and did we
is a day equal to holiday and when we
plug this all into that formula and
multiply it all out we get our
probability of a discount probability of
a free delivery probability of the day
being a holiday times the overall
probability of it being a purchase
divided by again multiplying the three
variables out the full probability of
there being a discount the full
probability of being a free delivery and
the full probability of there being a
day equal holiday and that's where we
get this 19 over 24 times 21 over 24
times 8 over 24 times the p of a 24 over
30 divided by the probability of the
discount the free delivery times the day
or 20 over 30 23 over 30 times 11 over
30 and that gives us our 0.986
so what are we going to do with these
two pieces of data we just generated
well let's go ahead and go over them we
have a probability of purchase equals
0.986 we have a probability of no
purchase equals 0.178
so finally we have a conditional
probabilities of purchase on this day
let us take that we're going to
normalize it and we're going to take
these probabilities and turn them into
percentages this is simply done by
taking the sum of probabilities which
equals 0.98686
plus 0.178 and that equals the 1.164
if we divide each probability by the sum
we get the percentage and so the
likelihood of a purchase is 84.71
percent and the likelihood of no
purchase is fifteen point two nine
percent given these three different
variables so it's if it's on a holiday
if it's a with a discount and has free
delivery then there's an eighty four
point seven one percent chance that the
customer is going to come in and make a
purchase hooray they purchased our stuff
we're making money if you're owning a
shop that's like is the bottom line is
you want to make some money so you can
keep your shop open and have a living
now i promised you that we were going to
be finishing up the math here with a few
pages so we're going to move on and
we're going to do two steps the first
step is i want you to understand
why you want to under why you want to
use the naive bayes what are the
advantages of naive bayes and then once
we understand those advantages we'll
just look at that briefly then we're
going to dive in and do some python
coding advantages of naive bayes
classifier so let's take a look at the
six advantages of the naive bayes
classifier and we're going to walk
around this lovely wheel looks like an
origami folded paper the first one is
very simple and easy to implement
certainly you could walk through the
tables and do this by hand you got to be
a little careful because the notations
can get confusing you have all these
different probabilities and i certainly
mess those up as i put them on you know
is it on the top of the bottom got to
really pay close attention to that when
you put it into python it's really nice
because you don't have to worry about
any of that you let the python handle
that the python module but understanding
it you can put it on a table and you can
easily see how it works and it's a
simple algebraic function it needs less
training data so if you have smaller
amounts of data this is great powerful
tool for that handles both continuous
and discrete data it's highly scalable
with number of predictors and data
points so as you can see just keep
multiplying different probabilities in
there and you can cover not just three
different variables or sets you can now
expand this to even more categories
number five it's fast it can be used in
real time predictions this is so
important this is why it's used in a lot
of our predictions on online shopping
carts uh referrals spam filters is
because there's no time delay as it has
to go through and figure out a neural
network or one of the other mini setups
where you're doing classification and
certainly there's a lot of other tools
out there in the machine learning that
can handle these but most of them are
not as fast as the naive bayes and then
finally it's not sensitive to irrelevant
features so it picks up on your
different probabilities and if you're
short on date on one probability you can
kind of it automatically adjust for that
those formulas are very automatic and so
you can still get a very solid
predictability even if you're missing
data or you have overlapping data for
two completely different areas we see
that a lot in doing census and studying
of people and habits where they might
have one study that covers one aspect
another one that overlaps and because
the two overlap they can then predict
the unknowns for the group that they
haven't done the second study on or vice
versa so it's very powerful in that it
is not sensitive to the irrelevant
features and in fact you can use it to
help predict features that aren't even
in there so now we're down to my
favorite part we're going to roll up our
sleeves and do some actual programming
we're going to do the use case text
classification now i would challenge you
to go back and send us a note on the
notes below underneath the video and
request the data for the shopping cart
so you can plug that into python code
and do that on your own time so you can
walk through it since we walk through
all the information on it but we're
going to do a python code doing text
classification very popular for doing
the naive bayes so we're going to use
our new tool to perform a text
classification of news headlines and
classify news into different topics for
a news website as you can see here we
have a nice image of the google news and
then related on the right subgroups i'm
not sure where they actually pulled the
actual data we're going to use from it's
one of the standard sets but certainly
this can be used on any of our news
headlines in classification so let's see
how it can be done using the naive bayes
classifier now we're at my favorite part
we're actually going to write some
python script roll up our sleeves and
we're going to start by doing our
imports these are very basic imports
including our news group and we'll take
a quick glance at the target names then
we're going to go ahead and start
training our data set and putting it
together we'll put together a nice graph
because it's always good to have a graph
to show what's going on and once we've
traded it and we've shown you a graph of
what's going on then we're going to
explore how to use it and see what that
looks like now i'm going to open up my
favorite editor or inline editor for
python you don't have to use this you
can use whatever your editor that you
like whatever interface ide you want
this just happens to be the anaconda
jupiter notebook and i'm going to paste
that first piece of code in here so we
can walk through it let's make it a
little bigger on the screen so you have
a nice view of what's going on and we're
using python 3 in this case 3.5 so this
would work in any of your 3x
if you have it set up correctly should
also work in a lot of the 2x you just
have to make sure all of the versions of
the modules match your python version
and in here you'll notice the first line
is your percentage matte plot library
inline now three of these lines of code
are all about plotting the graph
this one
lets the notebook notes as an inline
setup that we want the graphs to show up
on this page without it in a notebook
like this which is an explorer interface
it won't show up now a lot of ides don't
require that
a lot of them like on if i'm working on
one of my other setups it just has a
pop-up and the graph pops up on there so
you have that set up also but for this
we want the matplot library in line and
then we're going to import numpy as np
that's number python which has a lot of
different formulas in it that we use for
both of our sklearn module and we also
use it for any of the upper math
functions in python and it's very common
to see that as np numpy as np the next
two lines are all about our graphing
remember i said three of these were
about graphing well we need our matplot
library dot pi plot as plt and you'll
see that plt is a very common setup as
is the sns and just like the np and
we're going to import seaborne as sns
and we're going to do the sns.set
now seaborn sits on top of pie plot and
it just makes a really nice heat map
it's really good for heat maps and if
you're not familiar with heat maps that
just means we give it a color scale the
term comes from the brighter red it is
the hotter it is in some form of data
and you can set it to whatever you want
and we'll see that later on so those
you'll see that those three lines of
code here are just importing the graph
function so we can graph it and as a
data science test you always want to
graph your data and have some kind of
visual it's really hard just to shove
numbers in front of people and they look
at it and it doesn't mean anything and
then from the sklearn.datasets
we're going to import the fetch 20 news
groups very common one for analyzing
tokenizing words and setting them up and
exploring how the words work and how do
you categorize different things when
you're dealing with documents and then
we set our data equal to fetch 20 news
groups so our data variable will have
the data in it and we're going to go
ahead and just print the target names
data.target names and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see here we
have alt atheism comp graphics comp osms
windows.miscellaneous
and it goes all the way down to talk
politics dot miscellaneous talk religion
dot miscellaneous these are the
categories they've already assigned to
this news group and it's called fetch 20
because you'll see there's i believe
there's 20 different topics in here or
20 different categories as we scroll
down now we've gone through the 20
different categories and we're going to
go ahead and start defining all the
categories and set up our data so we're
actually getting here going to go ahead
and get it get the data all set up and
take a look at our data and let's move
this over to our jupyter notebook
and let's see what this code does
first we're going to set our categories
now if you noticed up here i could have
just as easily set this equal to
data.target underscore names because
it's the same thing but we want to kind
of spell it out for you so you can see
the different categories it kind of
makes it more visual so you can see what
your data is looking like in the
background once we've created the
categories
we're going to open up a train set so
this training set of data is going to go
into fetch 20 news groups and it's a
subset in there called train and
categories equals categories so we're
pulling out those categories that match
and then if you have a train set you
should also have the testing set we have
test equals fetch 20 news group subset
equals test and categories equals
categories let's go down one size so it
all fits on my screen there we go and
just so we can really see what's going
on let's see what happens when we print
out one part of that data
so
it creates train and under train it
creates train dot data and we're just
going to look at data piece number five
and let's go ahead and run that and see
what that looks like and you can see
when i print train dot data number five
under train it prints out one of the
articles this is article number five you
can go through and read it on there and
we can also go in here and change this
to test which should look identical
because it's splitting the data up into
different groups train and test and
we'll see test number five is a
different article but it's another
article in here and maybe you're curious
and you want to see just how many
articles are in here we could do
length
of train dot data and if we run that
you'll see that the training data has 11
314 articles so we're not going to go
through all those articles that's a lot
of articles but we can look at one of
them just you can see what kind of
information is coming out of it and what
we're looking at and we'll just look at
number five for today and here we have
it rewording the second amendment ids
vtt line 58 lines 58 in article uh etc
and scroll all the way down and see all
the different parts to there now we've
looked at it and that's pretty
complicated when you look at one of
these articles to try to figure out how
do you weight this if you look down here
we have different words and maybe the
word from well from is probably in all
the articles so it's not going to have a
lot of meaning as far as trying to
figure out whether this article fits one
of the categories or not so trying to
figure out which category fits in based
on these words is where the challenge
comes in now that we've viewed our data
we're going to dive in and do the actual
predictions this is the actual naive
bayes and we're going to throw another
model at you or another module at you
here in just a second we can't go into
too much detail but it deals
specifically working with words and text
and what they call tokenizing those
words
so let's take this code and let's skip
on over to our jupyter notebook and walk
through it and here we are in our
jupyter notebook let's paste that in
there and i can run this code right off
the bat it's not actually going to
display anything yet but it has a lot
going on in here so the top we had the
print module from the earlier one i
didn't know why that was in there so
we're going to start by importing our
necessary packages and from the sklearn
features extraction dot text we're going
to import tf idf vectorizer i told you
we're going to throw a module at you we
can't go too much into the math behind
this or how it works you can look it up
the notation for the math is usually
tf.idf
and that's just a way of weighing the
words and it weighs the words based on
how many times they're used in a
document how many times or how many
documents they're used in and it's a
well-used formula it's been around for a
while it's a little confusing to put
this in here
but let's let her know that it just goes
in there and waits the different words
in the document for us that way we don't
have to wait and if you put a weight on
it if you remember i was talking about
that up here earlier if these are all
emails they probably all have the word
from in them from probably has a very
low weight it has very little value in
telling you what this document's about
same with words like in an article in
articles in cost of on maybe cost might
or were words like criminal weapons
destruction these might have a heavier
weight because you describe a little bit
more what the article is doing well how
do you figure out all those weights in
the different articles that's what this
module does that's what the tf idf
vectorizer is going to do for us and
then we're going to import our
sklearn.naive bayes and that's our
multinomial nb
multinomial naive bayes pretty easy to
understand that where that comes from
and then finally we have the skylearn
pipeline import make pipeline now the
make pipeline is just a cool piece of
code because we're going to take the
information we get from the tf idf
vectorizer and we're going to pump that
into the multinomial nb
so a pipeline is just a way of
organizing how things flow it's used
commonly you probably already guessed
what it is if you've done any businesses
they talk about the sales pipeline
if you're on a work crew or project
manager you have your pipeline of
information that's going through or your
projects and what has to be done in what
order that's all this pipeline is
we're going to take the tfid vectorizer
and then we're going to push that into
the multinomial nb now we've designated
that as the variable model we have our
pipeline model and we're going to take
that model and this is just so elegant
this is done in just a couple lines of
code
model.fit and we're going to fit the
data and first the train data and then
the train target
now the train data has the different
articles in it you can see the one we
were just looking at and the train dot
target is what category they already
categorized that that particular article
as and what's happening here is the
train data is going into the tf id
vectorizer so when you have one of these
articles that goes in there it weights
all the words in there so there's
thousands of words with different
weights on them i remember once running
a model on this and i literally had 2.4
million tokens go into this
so when you're doing like large document
bases you can have a huge number of
different words it then takes those
words gives them a weight and then based
on that weight based on the words and
the weights and then puts that into the
multinomial nb and once we go into our
naive bayes
we want to put the train target in there
so the train data that's been mapped to
the tfid vectorizer is now going through
the multinomial in b and then we're
telling it well these are the answers
these are the answers to the different
documents so this document that has all
these words with these different weights
from the first part is going to be
whatever category it comes out of maybe
it's the
talk show or the article on religion
miscellaneous once we fit that model we
can then take labels and we're going to
set that equal to model.predict
most of the sklearn used the term dot
predict to let us know that we've now
trained the model and now we want to get
some answers and we're going to put our
test data in there because our test data
is the stuff we held off to the side we
didn't train it on there and we don't
know what's going to come up out of it
and we just want to find out how good
our labels are do they match what they
should be now i've already run this
through there's no actual output to it
to show this is just setting it all up
this is just trending our model creating
the labels so we can see how good it is
and then we move on to the next step to
find out what happened to do this we're
going to go ahead and create a confusion
matrix and a heat map so
the confusion matrix which is confusing
just by its very name is basically going
to ask how confused is our answer did it
get it correct or did it miss some
things in there or have some mis labels
and then we're going to put that on a
heat map so we'll have some nice colors
to look at to see how that plots out
let's go ahead and take this code and
see how that take a walk through it and
see what that looks like
so back to our jupiter notebook i'm
going to put the code in there and let's
go ahead and run that code
take it just a moment and remember we
had the inline that way my graph shows
up on the inline here
and let's walk through the code and then
we'll look at this and see what that
means so make it a little bit bigger
there we go no reason not to use the
whole screen too big so we have here
from sklearnmetrics import confusion
matrix
and that's just going to generate a set
of data that says i the prediction was
such the actual
truth was either agreed with it or is
something different and it's going to
add up those numbers so we can take a
look and just see how well it worked and
we're going to set a variable matt equal
to confusion matrix we have our test
target our test data that was not part
of the training
very important in data science we always
keep our test data separate
otherwise it's not a valid model if we
can't properly test it with new data and
this is the labels we created from that
test data these are the ones that we
predict it's going to be so we go in and
we create our sn heat map the sns is our
seaborn which sits on top of the pi plot
so we create a sns.heat map we take our
confusion matrix and it's going to be
mat dot t and do we have other
variables that go into the sns.heat map
we're not going to go into detail what
all the variables mean the annotation
equals true that's what tells it to put
the numbers here so you have the 166 the
one the zero zero zero one format d and
c bar equals false have to do with the
uh format if you take those out you'll
see that some things disappear and then
the x tick labels and the y tick labels
those are our target names and you can
see right here that's the alt atheism
comp graphics comp osms windows dot
miscellaneous and then finally we have
our
plt.xlabel remember the sns or the
seaborn sits on top of our matplot
library our plt and so we want to just
tell that x label equals a true is is
true the labels are true and then the y
label is prediction label so we say a
true this is what it actually is and the
prediction is what we predicted and
let's look at this graph because that's
probably a little confusing the way i
rattled through it and what i'm going to
do is i'm going to go ahead and flip
back to the slides because they have a
black background they put in there that
helps it shine a little bit better so
you can see the graph a little bit
easier so in reading this graph what we
want to look at is how the color scheme
has come out and you'll see a line right
down the middle diagonally from upper
left to bottom right what that is is if
you look at the labels we have our
predicted label on the left and our true
label on the right those are the numbers
where the prediction and the true come
together and this is what we want to see
is we want to see those lit up that's
what that heat map does as you can see
that it did a good job of finding those
data and you'll notice that there's a
couple of red spots on there where it
missed you know it's a little confused
we talk about talk religion
miscellaneous versus talk politics
miscellaneous social religion christian
versus alt atheism it mislabeled some of
those and those are very similar topics
so you could understand why it might
mislabel them but overall it did a
pretty good job if we're going to create
these models we want to go ahead and be
able to use them so let's see what that
looks like to do this let's go ahead and
create a definition a function to run
and we're going to call this function
let me just expand that just a notch
here there we go i like mine in big
letters predict categories we want to
predict the category we're going to send
it s a string and then we're sending it
train equals train we have our training
model and then we had our pipeline model
equals model this way we don't have to
resend these variables each time
the definition knows that because i said
train equals train and i put the equal
for model and then we're going to set
the prediction equal to the
model.predict s so it's going to send
whatever
string we send to it it's going to push
that string through the pipeline the
model pipeline it's going to go through
and tokenize it and put it through the
tf idf convert that into numbers and
weights for all the different documents
and words and then i'll put that through
our naive bayes and from it we'll go
ahead and get our prediction we're going
to predict what value it is and so we're
going to return train dot target names
predict
of zero and remember that the train dot
target names that's just categories i
could have just as easily put categories
in there dot predict of zero so we're
taking the prediction which is a number
and we're converting it to an actual
category we're converting it from i
don't know what the actual numbers are
but let's say zero equals alt atheism so
we're going to convert that zero to the
word or
one maybe it equals comp graphics so
we're going to convert number one into
comp graphics that's all that is and
then we gotta go ahead and and then we
need to go ahead and run this so i load
that up and then once i run that we can
start doing some predictions let me go
ahead and type in predict category
and let's just do predict category jesus
christ and it comes back and says it's
social religion christian that's pretty
good
now note i didn't put print on this one
the nice things about the jupiter
notebook editor and a lot of inline
editors is if you just put the name of
the variable out as returning the
variable train.target underscore names
it'll automatically print that for you
in your own id you might have to put in
print let's see where else we can take
this and maybe you're a space science
buff so how about sending
load to
international
space station
and if we run that
we get science space
or maybe you're a
automobile buff and let's do um oh
they're going to tell me audi is better
than bmw but i'm going to do bmw is
better
than an audi so maybe your car buff and
we run that and you'll see it says
recreational i'm assuming that's what
rec stands for autos so i did a pretty
good job labeling that one how about uh
if we have something like a caption
running through there president of india
and if we run that
it comes up and says talk politics
miscellaneous so when we take our
definition our function and we run all
these things through kudos we made it we
were able to correctly classify texts
into different groups based on which
category they belong to using the naive
bayes classifier now we did throw in the
pipeline the tf idf vectorizer we threw
in the graphs those are all things that
you don't necessarily have to know to
understand the naive bayes setup or
classifier but they're important to know
one of the main uses for the naive bayes
is with the tf idf tokenizer vectorizer
where tokenizes the word and as labels
and we use the pipeline because you need
to push all that data through and it
makes it really easy and fast you don't
have to know those understand naive
bayes but they certainly help for
understanding the industry and data
science and we can see our categorizer
our naive bayes classifier we were able
to predict the category religion space
motorcycles autos politics and properly
classify all these different things we
pushed into our prediction and our
trained model welcome to simply learn's
machine learning engineer salary skills
and resume who is a machine learning
engineer a machine learning engineer is
someone who performs the following tasks
develops and implements production-ready
algorithms and methods this is a very
difficult challenge because we talk
about production ready that's a key word
in here this is something that's going
to be pushed out to end users to be able
to use whether it's a bank doing their
finances or your
new cell phone where it's doing some
kind of image adjustment and adding in
virtual images or stamps onto the
picture code evolves machine learning
solutions with data scientists and
engineers so you're going to be working
as a team the data scientists are going
to be developing this and then you're
going to be implementing it provides
technical guidance to product teams on
the choice of machine learning
approaches appropriate for the task
machine learning engineers will design
implement and ship new algorithms
provides architectural guidance on
changing prototypes to high performance
production models and provides feedback
on tools and new features required to
send it back to the development teams so
let's dig a little deeper into the
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer they study and transform data
science prototypes design machine
learning systems
implement machine learning algorithms
develop machine learning applications
select appropriate data sets that is so
huge in the machine learning engineer is
how do you get these data sets in there
and how do you use the appropriate ones
and that's going to go back and forth to
your data scientists as a machine
learning engineer you want to be able to
recommend stuff for them and then they
got to go back and prototype it and then
it comes back to you to put it together
and start training these neural networks
perform statistical analysis and
fine-tuning and train and retrain
systems when necessary and that's also
another big one because there's a lot of
upkeep on these if you've ever seen the
evolution of any of the current
ais out there from google voice to
all the different picture programs and
everything there's a continual
retraining of these systems going on and
they continually improve so they're not
just rebuilding the whole thing from the
bottom up sometimes they're just
retraining them to get a better response
what's most exciting about this and what
most people are in here for is going to
be salary trends of a machine learning
engineer so where does that fit in in
the money show me the money and we look
at the salary trends the salary trends
of a machine learning engineer and we
look at the average base pay and this is
for the u.s it's 121 707
and you can see right there there's our
average around 122k low end is 83k so if
you're just getting into the field and
you're looking for a apprenticeship kind
of thing that's where you start looking
at 83k and then once you have that
high-end expertise now you're looking at
162k so it's got a really nice salary to
it in the us the average salary machine
learning engineer in the united states
is 121 707 per year and if we look at
that we skip over to india the average
salary of a machine learning engineer in
india is 750 000 per year 750 k in
indian standards and it ranges from the
lower 383 to 1584 k and that's important
to note that one of the interesting
things is in india if you're coming in
as an apprentice you have a lot more
room to breathe there and there's more
jobs available where in the us it's a
little harder to get in at the beginning
but once you're in there once you get
your foot in the door your salary just
shoots up with you know into the upper
end machine learning engineered jobs and
we're going to take this is just a pull
off of indeed's best jobs in the u.s and
comparing average base salary to
percentage growth and job postings 2015
to 2018 and this data was pulled back in
march of this year 2019. and you can see
here as we just kind of go across there
you can look at all the different
salaries going up and certainly the
machine learning engineer is just shot
up because it's one of the primary
growing fields and it's not stopping i
mean this this is we're in such an
infant stage of machine learning and
training and how do we get into these
deep learning models so the graph shows
the average base salary versus a growth
in job postings from 2015 to 2018. the
red line indicates the growth in job
postings a machine learning engineer it
is observed that machine learning
engineer has a
344 percent growth of job postings from
2015 to 2019. again that's not going to
stop that's just going to keep rising
because that is where a lot of the
actual work is right now stuff is being
pushed out they've got it working now
they need a machine learning engineer to
go in there and do all that retraining
and fine tuning
and that's a huge job and it's it's a
growing industry it's just going to
continue to take off so we look at top
companies hiring for machine learning
engineers we got amazon apple uh
deloitte i hope i said that right uber
facebook spotify google microsoft cisco
bosch
all of these should look for me these
are all the big tech companies and we're
starting to see it filter into the small
companies in fact i was just reading an
article that had one of the neural
networks that's used in deep learning
tensorflow has a tensorflow lite that
runs on an adreno board if you know
anything about adreno that is the 35
that's us dollar cheap computer in a box
that you can build something and strap
it on there and actually run a really
simple neural network obviously you're
not going to be doing some high-end
graphics but you can certainly use it
for doing a lot of little things so
across the board companies are hiring
machine learning engineers now when we
look at the skills of a machine learning
engineer as we start looking forward
machine learning engineers should have
the following skills one programming
pick a program master it if you don't
already you should have at least two
solid programs under your belt in
machine learning the top program right
now is python with a close following of
java there's also scala is very big
when we're talking about a lot of this
in any of these programs you should be
able to be really solid in one
programming skill and be able to adapt
to another one so having a secondary one
at least
should be important because you never
know when you walk into a job what
people want the program might start in
python and indian scala and then they
realize that they need to push it out of
the server and it's a java code that
they want so and it's not as hard as you
think to switch between the codes but it
does require you have a little knowledge
in each of those codes and be a master
of one applied mathematics you must have
basic understanding of math and this is
becoming less and less important but
it's still you need to have some
fundamental knowledge of your
mathematics data modeling and evaluation
that is so central to what starts
separating it from a programmer or from
a data scientist is your data modeling
and how to evaluate these different
models
so very important skill machine learning
algorithms and libraries that's just the
vocabulary it's a vocabulary of data
modeling and evolution machine learning
algorithms and libraries that's just the
language of data modeling and evaluation
you have to understand all the different
algorithms and libraries and what's
going on there so that you can model
different data and evaluate it under the
different models so let's take a look at
programming programming ability to adapt
implement and make changes to the
programs when required
programming languages like c c plus plus
java python r studio i didn't mention r
because that's also one of the big data
science programs that are out there and
again right now python just topped the
chart rstudio for data science java's
way up there see any of these are really
hardcore uh so master if you're if you
have a master and any of these great you
should know
something and be able to just glance
into python and probably glance a little
bit into r is important too because
those are the current data science
programs being used so you can actually
look at this and be able to know what to
pull and what to push we talk about
applied mathematics understanding of
matrixes that's that's probably the
thing that trips a lot of people up in
mathematics even people who are pretty
solid in mathematics start looking at
matrixes and they just start looking at
columns and rows and eyes go dilated so
understanding your matrixes and being
able to manipulate them derivatives and
integrals is necessary so you have an
understanding of your basic derivative
and what that means statistical concepts
like mean standard deviation is required
you really need to know those
terminologies and what the standard
deviation means what a square means any
of those concepts median versus mode
versus
any of those things those are so
important when you're doing applied
mathematics and you're looking at data
science and in this case the engineering
side of it and understanding of
probability algorithms like naive bayes
mixture models is required data modeling
and evaluation data modeling is a
process of finding the hidden structure
of a given data set and finding patterns
such as correlations and clusters a key
part of the process is evaluating how
good a given model is in choosing an
appropriate accuracy error measure and
an evaluation strategy now one of the
things i find interesting in the field
is that people start looking at the data
modeling and you can write a script that
goes through all the different models
and then you can take some of those
models and change all the different
underlying dimensions for that model
that takes up a lot of processing so you
might do that in very basic or small
part of your data set but as you fine
tune it you start learning that
understanding the it's almost like a
kind of a the art form of data modeling
right now is in this area is which how
do you find those correlations which
cluster control do you want uh do you
are you training it are you just finding
things that match some of these things
go with some other things you're just
clustering it based on their features
understanding all that is is really the
art form
digging into the data science and data
engineering side and as a machine
learning engineer this is important to
be able to understand as we look at
machine learning algorithms and
libraries you need a firm understanding
of algorithm concepts like linear
regression support vector machine k
means etc and understanding how these
algorithms work and so this is kind of a
re-hash of some of the other things we
saw earlier and this is a vocabulary you
need to know this vocabulary you need to
know when you're looking at a linear
regression model versus just a
regression model what's the difference
you can't just throw one into the other
well actually you can but if you throw
one into the other you don't get as good
of a result and then you waste a lot of
time messing with the wrong thing and
understanding your packages libraries
and apis like site kit learn that's part
of the mainly python although it's
spilling over and being adapted in other
areas theno tensorflow pandas and numpy
you know all huge packages currently
being run for the machine learning
algorithms
to give you an idea we'll go over to the
the simply learn website and you can see
uh data scientist here and when you come
in here you can see there's a whole
series a lot of times we start with our
programming this isn't by accident our
programming is was the standard of data
science for so long so you'll see data
science sas python data training sas has
come in that's a it's one of the major
players but it's not one of the big
programming languages um your python
your machine learning again here's a
more specific tableau which is very
highly used in the industry hadoop and
spark important to have a basics of big
data again this is all stuff as it's
going to come up if you're as a data
engineer or data scientist and there's a
lot of other ones here including all the
way through the master programming so a
lot of tools here that you can look up
and set up as far as getting your skills
up to par for being a machine learning
engineer and of course the bottom line
is um where's the money you know it's if
we're gonna train depending on where
you're at in your career a resume of
machine learning engineer is important
to understand and they've changed so
much i remember my first we won't talk
about how long ago my first paper in
machine learning was my first resume i
put out for work and job and
applications resumes have changed so
much and when we talk about something
like a machine learning engineer they're
going in leaps and bounds and let's just
go ahead and pop open a quick template
here and just show you some ideas of
what we're looking at so and i've opened
this up into a simple pdf reader adobe
acrobat reader one of the first things
is that and this always catches me off
guard as we're starting to see where we
want to see the person and you can
actually put your photo on the resume it
stands out they're going to remember you
you know wear a tie a suit and tie look
nice be a professional on this one but
that's a big thing now it catches people
eyes and we i've seen that forever say
in the real estate industry they hand
you their business card and it has their
photo on it even back in the 90s they
didn't care long as they had that visual
uh so we want a name a face an email id
contact number but we really want that
name in bold and we really want to see
who you are this is such a shift from
the way it used to be it used to be that
you did not want your personal stuff on
your resume now you do and of course the
summary is very important you can see
right here and again there's different
options on this so this format isn't
necessarily the only format you need to
use but this is a really good place to
start as you can see here we're actually
using almost a third of the page to put
your name put your summary and this next
part is another one another huge one
your linkedin profile if you have it um
they start looking at that and you have
all you post all of your stuff on there
nowadays they ask you hey what's your
history what's your employment history
and they can go down with your
certifications suddenly this linkedin
has all this massive amount information
that they can go pull and find out more
about you without having to go through
the resume so the resume is almost
secondary at some point and another
really important shift we see is where's
your github link or someplace maybe you
have a personal website
someplace you can show your skills in
coding your skills and what you do so
they no longer want to just have a
resume that says yeah i'm good they want
to actually see what you're capable of
this is a huge shift in resumes today
and with that i'm going to give a quick
warning there as a as i come in there
and i look up people and they say hey do
i want this person to work for me i'm
going to do a search on them they're
going to do a search on your name when
you're looking for a job so remember
your facebook and all your personalized
stuff if it is public make sure it's
professional you know you don't want to
have somebody go in there and decide
they don't like you because your
favorite rock band is imagine dragons or
and also keep in mind that sometimes
those facebook posts show up on somebody
else's feed so even though you think
you're private remember any of that
stuff could end up public and your
employer might be looking at that in
some jobs you might want to highlight
that if your specialty is marketing and
you're using facebook and marketing put
that in here uh so again it gives them
another link of what you do and what
you're doing on your resume we come down
to experience this can go in different
areas a lot of times if you have been in
the programming industry for years
you know i have over two decades as a
programmer this is almost a secondary
page sometimes where i just have all the
companies listed that i've worked for
with the blurb about what i did for them
again a lot of people just go to
linkedin and they already see that
information so they're going to skip
right over it so you might even bump it
down to the bottom and then your
education and skills in a lot of cases
you might take your skills and bump them
to the top highlight yourself and then
have your education certifications again
it depends on your history and what your
strength is if you have very specific
skills you're highlighting you might
want to bump this to the top so the
company is aware of it but again we have
a very basic blurb experience education
skills certifications this goes with
education sometimes arrange that that's
going to highlight you and show you off
the best so if you're really big on
certifications you might put those next
and just have two columns of all the
certifications you've gone through and
where they came from and then maybe your
education maybe you have oh an
associate's degree so you might have 20
different certifications and a two-year
associate's degree so the education
might go underneath your
certifications and so on again organize
this to highlight you and your strengths
and also to target the company you're
looking for in a resume i just love the
switch over here on the top and there's
even another suggestion you could even
do a personalized video again now they
have a this is a sales and marketing
thing we're starting to talk about where
we have a physical page they're looking
at hopefully you've talked to them on
the telephone so they have their voice
in the air and a video would be a third
input so the more the different inputs
they have fourth being the website maybe
a personal website would be fifth if you
have a facebook that's somewhat you know
professional on there and addressing and
addressing what you're going after put
that stuff in here the more input
somebody gets the more rounded they see
you and the more they might want to
employ you as a human being instead of
just another page on their stack of
people to go through so one of the first
questions that you may face is what are
the different types of machine learning
now what is the best way to respond to
this there are three types of machine
learning if you read any material you
will always be told there are three
types of machine learning but what is
important is you would probably be
better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where
you have some historical data and then
you feed the data to your model to learn
now you need to be aware of a keyword
that they will be looking for which is
labeled data right so if you just say
past data or historical data the impact
may not be so much you need to emphasize
on labeled data so what is label data
basically let's say if you are trying to
do train your model for classification
you need to be aware of for your
existing data which class each of the
observations belong to right so that is
what is labeling so it is nothing but a
fancy name you must be already aware but
just make it a point to throw in that
keyword labeled so that will have the
right impact okay so that is what is
supervised learning when you have
existing labeled data which you then use
to train your model that is known as
supervised learning and unsupervised
learning is when you don't have this
labeled data so you have data it is not
labeled so the system has to figure out
a way to do some analysis on this okay
so that is unsupervised learning and you
can then add a few things like what are
the ways of performing uh supervised
learning and unsupervised learning and
what are some of the techniques so
supervised learning we perform or we do
regression and classification
and unsupervised learning we do
clustering
and clustering can be of different types
similarly regression can be of different
types but you don't have to probably
elaborate so much if they are asking
for
just the different types you can just
mention these and just at a very high
level but if they want you to elaborate
give examples then of course i think
there is a different question for that
we will see that later then the third so
we have supervised then we have
unsupervised and then reinforcement you
need to provide a little bit of
information around that as well because
it is sometimes a little difficult to
come up with a good definition for
reinforcement learning so you may have
to little bit elaborate on how
reinforcement learning works right so
reinforcement learning works in in such
a way that it basically has two parts to
it one is the agent and the environment
and the agent basically is working
inside of this environment and it is
given a target that it has to achieve
and
every time it is moving in the direction
of the target so the agent basically has
to take some action and every time it
takes an action which is moving uh the
agent towards the target right towards a
goal a target is nothing but a goal then
it is rewarded and every time it is
going in a direction where it is away
from the goal then it is punished so
that is the way you can a little bit
explain and
this is used primarily or very very
impactful for teaching the system to
learn games and so on examples of this
are basically used in alphago you can
throw that as an example where alphago
used reinforcement learning to actually
learn to play the game of go and finally
it defeated the co-world champion right
this much of information that would be
good enough okay then there could be a
question on overfitting so the question
could be what is overfitting and how can
you avoid it so
what is overfitting so let's first try
to understand the concept because
sometimes overfitting may be a little
difficult to understand overfitting is a
situation where the model has kind of
memorized the data so this is an
equivalent of memorizing the data so we
can draw an analogy so that it becomes
easy to explain this now let's say
you're teaching a child about
recognizing some fruits or something
like that okay and you're teaching this
child about recognizing let's say three
fruits apples oranges and pineapples
okay so this is a small child and for
the first time you're teaching the child
to recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this
fruit and then first time obviously the
child will not know what it is so you
show an apple and you say hey this is
apple then you show maybe an orange and
say this is orange and so on and so
forth and then again you keep repeating
that right so till the basket is over
this is basically how training work in
machine learning also that's how
training works so till the basket is
completed maybe 100 fruits you keep
showing this child and then the process
what has happened the child has pretty
much memorized these so even before you
finish that basket right by the time you
are halfway through the child has learnt
about recognizing the apple orange and
pineapple now what will happen after
halfway through initially you remember
it made mistakes in recognizing but
halfway through now it has learned so
every time you show a fruit it will
exactly hundred percent accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jackfruit right so this is an equivalent
of your test data set which the child
has not seen before some parts of it it
probably has seen like the apples it has
seen but this banana and jackfruit it
has not seen so then what will happen in
the first round which is an equivalent
of your training data set towards the
end it has 100 percent it was telling
you what the fruits are right apple was
accurately recognized orange was
accurately recognized and pineapples
were accurately recognized right so that
is like 100 accuracy but now when you
get another a fresh set which we're not
part of the original one what will
happen all the apples maybe it will be
able to recognize correctly but all the
others like the jackfruit or the banana
will not be recognized by the child
right so this is an analogy this is an
equivalent of overfitting so what has
happened during the training process it
is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low loss right
so that is the technical term so the
loss is pretty much zero and accuracy is
pretty much 100 percent whereas when you
use testing there will be a huge error
which means the loss will be pretty high
and therefore the accuracy will be also
low okay this is known as overfitting
this is basically a process where
training is done training processes it
goes very well almost reaching 100
accuracy but while testing it really
drops down now how can you avoid it so
that is a extension of this question
there are multiple ways of avoiding
overfitting there are techniques like
what you call regularization that is the
most common technique that is used for
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like dropout in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but i
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have 1000 records with labeling
information now one way of doing it is
you use all the thousand records for
training and then maybe right which
means that you have exposed all these
thousand records during the training
process and then you take a small set of
the same data and then you say okay i
will test it with this okay and then you
probably what will happen you may get
some good results all right but there is
a flaw there what is the flaw this is
very similar to human beings it is like
you are showing this model the entire
data as a part of training okay so
obviously it has become familiar with
the entire data so when you are taking a
part of that again and you are saying
that i want to test it obviously you
will get good results so that is not a
very accurate way of testing so that is
the reason what we do is we have the
label data of this thousand records or
whatever we set aside before starting
the training process we set aside a
portion of the data and we call that
test set and the remaining we call as
training set and we use only this for
training our model now the training
process remember is not just about
passing one round of this data set so
let's say now your training set has 800
records it is not just one time you pass
this 800 records what you normally do is
you actually as a part of the training
you may pass this data through the model
multiple times so this thousand records
may go through the model maybe 10 15 20
times till the training is perfect till
the accuracy is high till the errors are
minimized okay now so which is fine
which means that your that is what is
known as the model has seen your data
and gets familiar with your data and now
when you bring your test data what will
happen is this is like some new data
because that is where the real test is
now you have trained the model and now
you are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like like a realistic
situation because when the model is
deployed that is what will happen it
will receive some new data not the data
that it has already seen right so this
is a realistic test so you put some new
data so this data which you have set
aside is for the model it is new and if
it is able to accurately predict the
values that means your training has
worked okay the model got trained
properly but let's say while you're
testing this with this test data you're
getting lot of errors that means you
need to probably either change your
model or retrain with more data and
things like that now coming back to the
question of how do you split this what
should be the ratio there is no fixed uh
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 50 test and 50 training some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for test
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something that the
ratio has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around uh data
handling data manipulation or what you
call data management or preparation so
these are all some questions around that
area there is again no one answer one
single good answer to this it really
varies from situation to situation and
depending on what exactly is the problem
what kind of data it is how critical it
is what kind of data is missing and what
is the type of corruption so the whole
lot of things this is a very generic
question and therefore you need to be
little careful about responding to this
as well so probably have to illustrate
this again if you have experience in
doing this kind of work in handling data
you can illustrate with examples saying
that i was on one project where i
received this kind of data these were
the columns where data was not filled or
these were the this many rows where the
data was missing that would be in fact a
perfect way to respond to this question
but if you don't have that obviously you
have to provide some good answer i think
it really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the missing data or corrupt
data now let's take a few examples now
let's say you have data where some
values in some of the columns are
missing and you have pretty much half of
your data having these missing values in
terms of number of rows okay that could
be one situation another situation could
be that you have records or data missing
but when you do some initial calculation
how many records are correct or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like 10 percent okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so
it is not so mission critical and it is
okay to let's say get rid of these
records so obviously one of the easiest
ways of handling the data part or
missing data is remove those records or
remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as i said in
as in the first case if let's say 50 of
your data is like that because some
column or the other way is missing so it
is not like every in every place in
every row the same column is missing but
you have in maybe 10 percent of the
records column one is missing and
another ten percent column two is
missing another ten percent column three
is missing and so on and so forth so it
adds up to maybe half of your data set
so you cannot completely remove half of
your data set then the whole purpose is
lost okay so then how do you handle then
you need to come up with ways of filling
up this data with some meaningful value
right that is one way of handling so
when we say meaningful value what is
that meaningful let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
for a task right there may be situations
where if the missing values instead of
putting mean may be a good idea to fill
it up with the minimum value or with a
zero so or with the maximum value again
as i said there are so many
possibilities so there is no like one
correct answer for this you need to
basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as i
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so
then the next question can be how can
you choose a classifier based on a
training set data size so again this is
one of those questions
where you probably do not have like a
one size fits all answer first of all
you
may not let's say
decide your classifier based on the
training set size maybe not the best way
to decide the type of the classifier and
even if you have to there are probably
some thumb rules which we can use but
then again every time so in my opinion
the best way to respond to this question
is you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so
you will never be able to just by if
somebody defines a problem to you and
somebody even if they show the data to
you or tell you what is the data or even
the size of the data i don't think there
is a way to really say that yes this is
the classifier that will work here no
that's not the right way so you need to
still uh you know test it out get the
data try out a couple of classifiers and
then only you will be in a position to
decide which classifier to use you try
out multiple classifiers see which one
gives the best accuracy and only then
you can decide then you can have a
question around confusion matrix so the
question can be explained confusion
matrix right so confusion matrix i think
the best way to explain it is by taking
an example and drawing like a small
diagram otherwise it can really become
tricky so my suggestion is to take a
piece of pen and paper and
explain it by drawing a small matrix and
confusion matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification learning process and when
you get the results and our model
predicts the results you compare it with
the actual value and try to find out
what is the accuracy okay so
in this case let's say this is an
example of a confusion matrix and
it is a binary matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many know so you have that
efficient and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many know
right so the total actual values the
total yes is 12 plus 113 and they are
shown here and the actual value those
are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is what
this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are one plus nine ten nose okay so
this is the way to look at this
confusion matrix okay and uh out of this
what is the meaning conveying so there
are two or three things that needs to be
explained outright the first thing is
for a model to be accurate the values
across the diagonal should be high like
in this case right that is one number
two the total sum of these values is
equal to the total observations in the
test data set so in this case for
example you have 12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25
so that means we have 25 observations in
our test data set okay so these are the
two things you need to first explain
that the total sum in this matrix the
numbers is equal to the size of the test
data set and the diagonal values
indicate the accuracy so by just by
looking at it you can probably have a
idea about is this uh an accurate model
is the model being accurate if they're
all spread out equally in all these four
boxes that means probably the accuracy
is not very good okay now how do you
calculate the accuracy itself right how
do you calculate the accuracy itself so
it is a very simple mathematical
calculation you take some of the
diagonals right so in this case it is 9
plus 12 21 and divide it by the total so
in this case what will it be let me take
a pen so your your diagonal values is
equal to if i say d is equal to 12 plus
9 so that is 21 right and the total data
set is equal to right we just calculated
it is 25 so what is your accuracy it is
21 by your accuracy is equal to 21 by 25
and this turns out to be about 85
percent right so this is 85
so that is our accuracy okay so this is
the way you need to explain draw diagram
give an example and maybe it may be a
good idea to be prepared with an example
so that it becomes easy for you don't
have to calculate those numbers on the
fly right so a couple of
hints are that you take some numbers
which are with which add up to 100 that
is always a good idea so you don't have
to really do this complex calculations
so the total value will be 100 and then
diagonal values you divide once you find
the diagonal values that is equal to
your percentage okay all right so the
next question can be a related question
about
false positive and false negative so
what is false positive and what is false
negative now once again the best way to
explain this is using a piece of paper
and pen otherwise it will be pretty
difficult to explain this so we use the
same example of the confusion matrix
and
we can explain that so a confusion
matrix looks somewhat like this and
when we just
yeah it looks somewhat like this and we
continue with the previous example where
this is the actual value this is the
predicted value and uh in the actual
value we have 12 plus 1 13 yeses and 3
plus 9 12 knows and the predicted values
there are 12 plus the 15 yeses and
1 plus 9 10 nos okay now this particular
case which is the false positive what is
a false positive first of all the second
word which is positive okay is referring
to the predicted value so that means the
system has predicted it as a positive
but the real value so this is what the
false comes from but the real value is
not positive okay that is the way you
should understand this term false
positive or even false negative so false
positive so positive is what your system
has predicted so where is that system
predicted this is the one positive is
what yes so you basically consider this
row okay now if you consider this row so
this is this is all positive values this
entire row is positive values okay now
the false positive is the one which
where the value actual value is negative
predicted value is positive but the
actual value is negative so this is a
false positive right and here is a true
positive so the predicted value is
positive and the actual value is also
positive okay i hope this is making
sense now let's take a look at what is
false negative false negative so
negative is the second term that means
that is the predicted value that we need
to look for so which are the predicted
negative values this row corresponds to
predicted negative values all right so
this row corresponds to predicted
negative values and what they are asking
for false so this is the row for
predicted negative values and the actual
value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is a way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right nine is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the
steps involved in the machine learning
process or what are the three steps in
the process of developing a machine
learning model and so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably
decide that there is one particular
algorithm which is more suitable usually
it happens through trial and error
process but at some point you will
decide that okay this is the model we
are going to use okay so in that case we
have the model algorithm and the model
decided and then you need to do the
process of training the model and
testing the model and this is where if
it is supervised learning you split your
data the label data into training data
set and test data set and you use the
training data set to train your model
and then you use the test data set to
check the accuracy whether it is working
fine or not so you test the model before
you actually put it into production
right so once you test the model you're
satisfied it's working fine then you go
to the next level which is putting it
for production and then in production
obviously new data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression or classification now so this
can be an iterative process so it is not
a straightforward process where you do
the training through the testing and
then you move it to production now so
during the training and test process
there may be a situation where because
of either overfitting or
things like that the test doesn't go
through which means that you need to put
that back into the training process so
that can be an iterative process not
only that even if the training and test
goes through properly and you deploy the
model in production there can be a
situation that the data that actually
comes the real data that comes with that
this model is failing so in which case
you may have to once again go back to
the drawing board or initially it will
be working fine but over a period of
time maybe due to the change in the
nature of the data once again the
accuracy will deteriorate so that is
again a recursive process so once in a
while you need to keep checking whether
the model is working fine or not and if
required you need to tweak it and modify
it and so on and so forth so let net
this is a continuous process of uh
tweaking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with ai artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is a deep learning so i
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and
then obviously the question would be
then what is the difference right so
deep learning you need to mention there
are two key parts that interviewer will
be looking for when you are defining
deep learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say
scope and deep learning is one part of
it so then what exactly is the
difference deep learning is primarily
when we are implementing these our
algorithms or when we are using neural
networks for doing our training and
classification and regression and all
that right so when we use neural network
then it is considered as deep learning
and the term deep comes from the fact
that you can have several layers of
neural networks and these are called
deep neural networks and therefore the
term deep you know deep learning the
other difference between machine
learning and deep learning which the
interviewer may be wanting to hear is
that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and
this data has several let's say if it is
a regular table it has several columns
now each of these columns actually has
information about a feature right so if
we are trying to predict the height
weight and so on and so forth so these
are all features of human beings let's
say we have census data and we have all
this so those are the features now there
may be probably 50 or 100 in some cases
there may be 100 such features now all
of them do not contribute to our model
right so we as a data scientist we have
to decide whether we should take all of
them all the features or we should throw
away some of them because again if we
take all of them number one of course
your accuracy will probably get affected
but also there is a computational part
so if you have so many features and then
you have so much data it becomes very
tricky so in case of machine learning we
manually take care of identifying the
features that do not contribute to the
learning process and thereby we
eliminate those features and so on right
so this is known as feature engineering
and in machine learning we do that
manually whereas in deep learning where
we use neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably
will add value to your response all
right so the next question is what is
the difference between or what are the
differences between machine learning and
deep learning so here this is a quick
comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
machines to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and
it needs only a small amount of data for
training and then works well on low-end
systems so you don't need large machines
and most features need to be identified
in advance and manually coded so
basically the feature engineering part
is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural nets
so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the machine
learning features are or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but uh the
meaning is how exactly is machine
learning used or actually supervised
machine learning it could be a very
specific question around supervised
decision learning so this is like give
examples of supervised machine learning
use of supervised machine learning in
modern business so that could be the
next question so there are quite a few
examples or quite a few use cases if you
will for supervised machine learning the
very common one is email spam detection
so you want to train your application or
your system to detect between spam and
non-spam so this is a very common
business application of a supervised
machine learning so how does this work
the way it works is that you obviously
have historical data about of your
emails and they are categorized as spam
and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have label data you already have emails
which are tagged as spam or not spam and
then you use that to train your model
right so this is one example now there
are a few industry specific applications
for supervised machine learning one of
the very common ones is in healthcare
diagnostics in healthcare diagnostics
you have these images and you want to
train models to detect whether from a
particular image whether it can find out
if the person is sick or not whether a
person has cancer or not right so this
is a very good example of supervised
machine learning here the way it works
is that existing images it could be
x-ray images it'd be mri or any of these
images are available and they are tagged
saying that okay this x-ray image is
defective or the person has an illness
or it could be cancer whichever illness
right so it is tagged as a defective or
clear or good image and defective
something like that so we come up with a
binary or it could be multi-class as
well saying that this is defective to 10
this is 25 and so on but let's keep it
simple you can give an example of just a
binary classification that would be good
enough so
you can say that in healthcare
diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when new
image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so i think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
uh unsupervised and so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of diagnostic images we can
just let's say take x-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
their images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good that
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so i know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no quick and easy
definition for semi-supervised machine
learning this is the only way probably
to explain this concept
we may have another question as
what are unsupervised machine learning
techniques or what are some of the
techniques used for performing
unsupervised machine learning so it can
be worded in different ways so how do we
answer this question so unsupervised
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then association you can i
think the best way to explain
association is with an example in case
of association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought
maybe a laptop the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying and laptops are also
buying the mouse so that means there is
an association between laptops and mouse
or maybe people who are buying bread are
also buying butter so that is the
association that can be created so this
is unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so
machine learning these are the two main
types of machine learning supervised and
unsized and in case of supervised and
again here probably the key word that
the person may be wanting to hear is
labeled data very often people say we
have historical data and if we run it it
is supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
label okay so when we have labeled data
for training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have label data then we use unsupervised
learning and there are different
algorithms available to perform both of
these types of trainings so there can be
another question a little bit more
theoretical and conceptual in nature
this is about inductive machine learning
and
deductive machine learning so the
question can be what is the difference
between inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning or
somewhat in that manner so that the
exact phrase or exact question can vary
they can ask for examples and things
like that but that could be the question
so let's first understand what is
inductive and deductive training
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with the small example i think that
always helps so whenever you're doing
some explanation try as much as possible
as i said to give examples from your
work experience or give some analogies
and that will also help a lot in
explaining as well and for the
interviewer also to understand so here
we'll take an example or rather we will
use an analogy so inductive training is
when we induce some knowledge or the
learning process into a person without
the person actually experiencing it okay
what can be an example so we can
probably tell the person or show a
person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage right so this is
inductive learning compared to that what
is deductive learning so here you draw
conclusion or the person draws
conclusion out of experience so we will
stick to the analogy so compared to the
showing a video let's assume a person is
allowed to play with fire right and then
he figures out that if he puts his
finger it's burning or if throw
something into the fire it burns so he
is learning through experience so this
is known as deductive learning okay so
you can have applications or models that
can be trained using inductive learning
or deductive learning all right i think
uh probably that explanation will be
sufficient
the next question is are knn and k means
clustering similar to one another or are
they same right because the letter k is
kind of common between them okay so let
us take a little while to understand
what these two are one is k nn another
is k means a k n stands for k nearest
neighbors and k means of course is the
clustering mechanism now these two are
completely different except for the
letter k being common between them knn
is completely different k means
clustering is completely different
knnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
isk process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k means clustering is
actually unsupervised okay when you have
k and n when you want to implement k and
n which is basically k nearest neighbors
the value of k is a number so you can
say k is equal to 3 you want to
implement k n with k is equal to 3 so
which means that it performs the
classification in such a way that how
does it perform the classification so it
will take three nearest objects and
that's why it's called nearest neighbor
so basically based on the distance it
will try to find out its nearest objects
that are let's say three of the nearest
objects and then it will check whether
the class they belong to which class
right so if all three belong to one
particular class obviously this new
object is also classified as that
particular class but it is possible that
they may be from two or three different
classes okay so let's say they are from
two classes and then if they are from
two classes now usually you take a odd
number you assign a odd number to so if
there are three of them and two of them
belong to one class and then one belongs
to another class so this new object is
assigned to the class to which the two
of them belong now the value of k is
sometimes tricky whether should you use
3 should you use 5 should you use 7 that
can be tricky because the ultimate
classification can also vary so it's
possible that if you are taking k as 3
the object is probably in one particular
class but if you take uh k is equal to
five maybe the object will belong to a
different class because when you are
taking three of them probably two of
them belong to a class one and one
belong to class two whereas when you
take five of them it is possible that
only two of them belong to class one and
the three of them belong to class two so
which means that this object will belong
to class two right so you see that so it
is the class allocation can vary
depending on the value of k now k means
on the other hand is a clustering
process and it is unsupervised where
what it does is the system will
basically identify how the objects are
how close the objects are with respect
to some of their features okay and but
similarity of course is the the letter k
and in case of k means also we specify
its value and it could be three or five
or seven there is no technical limit as
such but it can be any number of
clusters that you can create okay so
based on the value that you provide the
system will create that many clusters of
similar objects so there is a similarity
to that extent that k is a number in
both the cases but actually these two
are completely different processes
we have what is known as naive bayes
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive bayes is the name of
the person who found this uh classifier
order who developed this classifier
which is not 100 percent true base is
the name of the person bayes is the name
of the person but naive is not the name
of the person right so naive is
basically an english word and that has
been added here because of the nature of
this particular classifier naive bayes
classifier is a probability based
classifier and
it makes some assumptions that
presence of one feature of a class is
not related to the presence of any other
feature of maybe other classes right so
which is not a very strong or not a very
what do you say accurate assumption
because these features can be related
and so on but even if we go with this
assumption this whole algorithm works
very well even with this assumption and
that is the good side of it but the term
comes from that so that is the
explanation that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
has an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
actions in order to achieve a certain
goal and this goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score high value high number
or it could be that your
number of lives should be as high as
possible don't lose life so this could
be some of them more advanced examples
could be for driving in the automotive
industry self-driving cars they actually
also make use of reinforcement learning
to teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize the
number of lives and so on or minimize
the debts for example it is rewarded and
every time it takes a step which goes
against that core right contrary or in
the reverse direction it is penalized
okay so it is like a carrot and stick
system now how do you use this to create
a game of chess or to create a system to
play a game of chess now the way this
works is and this could probably go back
to this alphago example where alphago
defeated a human champion so the way it
works is in reinforcement learning the
system is allowed for example in this
case we are talking about chess so we
allow the system to first of all watch
playing a game of chess so it could be
with a human being or it could be the
system itself there are computer games
of chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch a human being
play the game
because this is reinforcement
learning is pretty much all visual so
when you're teaching the system to play
a game the system will not actually go
behind the scenes to understand the
logic of your software of this game or
anything like that it is just visually
watching the screen and then it learns
okay so reinforcement learning to a
large extent it works on that so you
need to create a mechanism whereby your
model will be able to watch somebody
playing the game and then you allow the
system also to start playing the game so
it pretty much starts from scratch okay
and as it moves forward it it's at right
at the beginning the system really knows
nothing about the game of chess okay so
initially it is a clean slate it just
starts by observing how you're playing
so it will make some random moves and
keep losing badly but then what happens
is over a period of time so you need to
now
allow the system or you need to play
with the system not just one two three
four or five times but hundreds of times
thousands of times maybe even hundreds
of thousands of times and that's exactly
how alphago has done it played millions
of games between itself and the system
right so for the game of chess also you
need to do something like that you need
to allow the system to pitch us and
learn on its own over a period of
repetitions so i think you can probably
explain it after this much to this
extent and it should be
sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem i would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm i am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have svm you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes so for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is not possible okay so we
have to try out a bunch of algorithms
see which one gives us the best
performance best accuracy and then
decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is no real possibility that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use then the questions
may be around application of machine
learning and this question is
specifically around how amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does the recommendation
engine work so this is basically the
question is all about so the
recommendation engine again works based
on various inputs that are provided
obviously something like uh you know
amazon on a website or e-commerce site
like amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they are also
buying something else so this kind of
association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build association
between items saying that somebody
buying this is also buying this that is
one part of it then they also profile
the users right based on their age their
gender their geographic location they
will do some profiling and then when
somebody is logging in and when somebody
is shopping kind of the mapping of these
two things are done they try to identify
obviously if you have logged in then
they know who you are and your
information is available like for
example your age may be your agenda and
where you're located what you purchased
earlier right so all this is taken and
the recommendation engine basically uses
all this information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user so
that is how the recommendation engine
works all right then the question can be
something very basic like when will you
go for classification versus regression
right when do you do classification
instead of regression or when would you
use classification instead of regression
now yes so so this is basically going
back to the understanding of the basics
of classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
we are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if you
are trying to find some discrete values
you use classification and then you need
to illustrate what are some of the
examples so classification is like let's
say there are images and you need to put
them into classes like cat dog elephant
tiger something like that so that is a
classification a problem or it can be
that is a multi-class classification
problem it could be binary
classification problem like for example
whether a customer will buy or he will
not buy that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not that's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continuous so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your concepts and things like
that so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
develop a spam filter so i think the
main thing here is he is looking at
probably understanding your concepts in
terms of what is the algorithm you will
use or what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression and things like that and the
process of course the methodology and
the process so the best way to go about
responding to this is we say that okay
this is a classification problem because
we want to find out whether an email is
a spam or not spam so that we can apply
the filter accordingly so first thing is
to identify what type of a problem it is
so we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as i said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support vector missions for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually
so
and you actually will have three models
let's say you are trying to test out
three algorithms so you will obviously
have three models so you need to try all
three models and test them out as well
see which one gives the best accuracy
and then you decide that you will go
with that model okay so training and
test will be done and then you zero in
on one particular model and then you say
okay this is the model will be used we
will use and then go ahead and implement
that or put that in production so that
is the way you design a spam file the
next question is about random forest
what is random forest so this is a very
straightforward question however the
response you need to be again a little
careful while we all know what is random
forest explaining this can sometimes be
tricky so one thing is random forest is
kind of in one way it is an extension
of decision trees because it is
basically nothing but you have multiple
decision trees and
trees will basically you will use for
doing if it is classification mostly it
is classification you will use the trees
for classification and then you use
voting for finding that the final class
so that is the underlyings but how will
you explain this how will you respond to
this so first thing obviously we will
say that random forest is one of the
algorithms and the more important thing
that you need to probably the
interviewer is waiting to hear is
ensemble learner right so this is one
type of ensemble learner what is
ensemble learner ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one or maybe
models okay so in case of random forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a random forest is an ensemble
learner there are other types of
ensemble learners where we have like we
use different algorithms itself so you
have one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about ensembl we will not go into that
but random foreign i think the
interviewer will be happy to hear this
word ensemble learners and so then you
go and explain how the random forest
works so if the random forest is used
for classification then we use what is
known as a voting mechanism so basically
how does it work let's say your random
forest consists of 100 trees okay and
each observation you pass through this
forest and each observation let's say it
is a classification problem binary
classification zero or 1 and you have
100 trees now if 90 trees say that it is
a 0 and 10 of the trees say it is a 1
you take the majority you may take a
vote and since 90 of them are saying 0
you classify this as 0 then you take the
next observation and so on so that is
the way random forest works for
classification if it is a regression
problem it's somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of what what we will do
is sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you're using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
100 trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the 100 trees right so
this is also a way of reducing the error
so maybe if you have only one tree and
if that one tree makes a error it is
basically hundred percent wrong or 100
right right but if you have on the other
hand if you have a bunch of trees you
are basically mitigating that
reducing that error okay so that is the
way random forest works so the next
question is considering the long list of
machine learning algorithms how will you
decide on which one to use so once again
here there is no way to outright say
that this is the algorithm that we will
use for a given data set this is a very
good question but then the response has
to be like again there will not be a one
size fits all so
we need to first of all you can probably
shorten the list in terms of by saying
okay whether it is a classification
problem or it is a regression problem to
that extent you can probably shorten the
list because you don't have to use all
of them if it is a classification
problem you only can pick from the
classification algorithms right so for
example if it's a classification you
cannot use linear regression algorithm
or if it is a regression problem you
cannot use svm or maybe now you can use
svm but maybe a logistic regression
right so to that extent you can probably
shorten the list but still you will not
be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that i am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm okay
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variance so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning uh so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual values so that
is the bias okay and whereas they are
all all the values are probably they are
far off but they are very near to each
other though the predicted values are
close to each other right while they are
far off from the actual value but they
are close to each other you see the
difference so that is bias and then the
other part is your variance now variance
is when the predicted values are all
over the place right so the variance is
high that means it may be close to the
target but it is kind of very scattered
so the points the predicted values are
not close to each other right in case of
bias the predicted values are close to
each other but they are not close to the
target
is the trade-off between bias and
variance yes i think this is a
interesting question because these two
are
heading in different directions so for
example if you try to minimize the bias
variance will keep going high and if you
try to minimize the variance bias will
keep going high and there is no way you
can minimize both of them so you need to
have a trade-off saying that okay this
is the level at which i will have my
bias and this is the level at which i
will have variance so the trade-off is
that pretty much uh attack you you
decide what is the level you will
tolerate for your bias and what is the
level you will tolerate for variance and
a combination of these two in such a way
that your final results are not way off
and having a trade-off will ensure that
the results are consistent right so that
is basically the output is consistent
and which means that they are close to
each other and they are also accurate
that means they are as close to the
target as possible right so if either of
these is high then one of them will go
off the track define precision and
recall now again here i think it would
be best to
draw a diagram and take
the confusion matrix and it is very
simple the definition is like a formula
your precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that's pretty much you know that can be
shown that's the easiest way to define
so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
pruning and why is it so
basically decision trees are really
simple to implement and understand but
one of the drawbacks of decision trees
is that it can become highly complicated
as it grows right and the rules and the
conditions can become very complicated
and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100 accuracy but when
you're doing testing you'll get a lot of
errors so that is the reason pruning
needs to be done so the purpose or the
reason for doing
decision tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on
overfitting and what is decision tree
pruning it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then there are several internal
nodes and then you have the leaf nodes
now if there are too many of these
internal nodes that is when you face the
problem of overfitting and pruning is
the process of reducing those internal
nodes all right so the next question can
be what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is
one of the techniques used for
performing classification especially
binary classification now there is
something special about logistic
regression and there are a couple of
things you need to be careful about
first of all the name is a little
confusing it is called logistic
regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really you know if it is required and
they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation involves log and therefore
the name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a zero
or a one and it varies so it's basically
it calculates a probability between 0
and 1 and we can set a threshold that
can vary typically it is 0.5 so any
value above 0.5 is considered as 1 and
if the probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as 0. so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates the probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of 0 or 1
which is like a binary classification 0
or okay then we have a question around k
nearest neighbor algorithm so explain k
nearest neighbor algorithm so first of
all what is a k nearest neighbor
algorithm this is a classification
algorithm so that is the first thing we
need to mention and we also need to
mention that the k is a number it is an
integer and this is variable and we can
define what the value of k should be it
can be 2 3 5 7 and usually it is an odd
number so that is something we need to
mention technically it can be even
number also but then typically it would
be odd number and we will see why that
is okay so based on that we need to
classify objects okay we need to
classify objects so again it will be
very helpful to draw a diagram you know
if you're explaining i think that will
be the best way so draw some diagram
like this and let's say we have three
clusters or three classes existing and
now you want to find for a new item that
has come you want to find out which
class this belongs to right so you go
about as the name suggests it you go
about finding the nearest neighbors
right the points which are closest to
this and how many of them you will find
that is what is defined by k now let's
say our initial value of k was five
so you will find the k the five nearest
data points so in this case as it is
illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are a one belonging to this
cluster one the second one belonging to
this cluster two three of them belonging
to this third cluster okay so how do you
decide that's exactly the reason we
should as much as possible try to assign
an odd number so that it becomes easier
to assign this so in this case you see
that the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as i
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so k
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of neighbors that
are mentioned as k so in this case it is
k is equal to 5 so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the
new data point is assigned to that class
okay so that's pretty much how k nearest
neighbors work thank you all for
watching this video on machine learning
tutorial by simplylon i hope you liked
it stay tuned for more from simply alone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you